Desperate times, my friends, call for desperate measures. Ora was in college when something mysterious happened. She was at her computer editing.
朋友们，绝望的时刻需要绝望的手段。奥拉上大学时，发生了一件神秘的事情。当时她正在电脑前剪辑。
And I was editing, editing, looking at this computer, and my eyesight started to go blurry. And I just couldn't really see the computer that well. And I was like, I need to stop. I can't really see anymore. And I was walking home, and everything's just blurry.
我当时在剪辑，盯着电脑，视力开始模糊。我真的看不清电脑。我当时想，我得停下来，我真的看不见了。我走回家时，眼前的一切都是模糊的。
An eye doctor examined her, said there was nothing wrong with her eyes to cause the blurriness.
一位眼科医生检查了她，说她的眼睛没有问题，不会导致视力模糊。
And then-- oh, I remember I had weird heart palpitations. So I went to the doctor to get an EKG, and they were like, you seem fine. Maybe you're just in love.
然后——哦，我记得我有过奇怪的心悸。所以我去看医生做了心电图，他们说，你看起来很正常。也许你只是坠入爱河了。
Pause on that. That was really a thing that happened to you? You showed up with medical symptoms, and they said, maybe you're in love?
暂停一下。这真的是发生在你身上的事吗？你带着病症去看医生，他们说，也许你坠入爱河了？
Yeah.
是的。
She was actually falling in love, but she did not think that explained the heart palpitations. She was starting to get the feeling that people were not taking her seriously. And things were getting worse.
她确实在坠入爱河，但她认为这无法解释心悸。她开始感觉到人们没有认真对待她。情况变得越来越糟。
It just feels like everything in my body is breaking in a weird way-- terrible fatigue, horrible brain fog, and this feeling in the left side of my brain. Just, like, the best way I can describe it is I feel like an ice cream scoop has been taken out of my head.
感觉就像我身体里的每一部分都在以一种奇怪的方式崩坏——极度的疲劳、可怕的脑雾，以及左脑的那种感觉。我能描述的最好的方式是，我觉得我的大脑像是被挖掉了一勺冰淇淋。
Symptoms like that come and go for two years-- blurry vision. Her legs are weak and tremble. Her throat swells up, and it feels like she's being strangled. And then some stuff is constant. She's exhausted, but can't sleep-- pressure headaches. It's hard to think. This derails her life. She's always taking time off from work or showing up late in the day. Can't be on the computer for too long, which limits what jobs she can get. She's going to the doctor all the time. She's too tired to go out with friends at night. Remember, she's in her 20s.
像这样的症状来来去去持续了两年——视力模糊。她的腿无力且颤抖。她的喉咙肿胀，感觉像是被人扼住咽喉。而且有些症状是持续的。她精疲力竭，却无法入睡——压迫性头痛。思考变得很困难。这摧毁了她的生活。她总是请假或迟到。不能在电脑前待太久，这限制了她能从事的工作。她一直在看医生。她太累了，晚上无法和朋友出去玩。记住，她才20多岁。
A tip on Reddit-- of course, Reddit-- leads her to believe that she may have Lyme disease, even though she'd already been tested for Lyme disease, and it came up negative. No Lyme. A different doctor now tests her again, and this time, she tests positive for Lyme. So the doctor prescribes the standard treatment for Lyme, doxycycline, this antibiotic-- doesn't work for her. Then she spends two years on other antibiotics and other drugs. Those fail, too.
Reddit上的一个建议——当然是Reddit——让她相信自己可能患有莱姆病，尽管她已经接受过莱姆病检测，结果是阴性。没有莱姆病。现在另一位医生重新给她做了测试，这次呈阳性。于是医生开了莱姆病的标准治疗药物——多西环素，这种抗生素对她没用。然后她又花了两年时间服用其他抗生素和药物。那些也失败了。
Maybe-- it's possible-- this was because she didn't really have Lyme disease. That second test she took for Lyme was not an FDA-approved test. This is the nightmarish world of Lyme, this whole debate over who really has it and who just has symptoms. From Ora's point of view, the question was moot. She had the symptoms. She wanted them gone.
也许——有可能——这是因为她根本就没有患莱姆病。她做的第二次莱姆病测试并非美国食品药品监督管理局（FDA）批准的测试。这就是莱姆病的噩梦世界，关于谁真正患病而谁只是有症状的争论。从奥拉的角度来看，这个问题毫无意义。她有症状。她只想摆脱它们。
Regular doctors weren't doing it, so she started looking at all the other treatments that people try for these symptoms-- and there are a lot of them. She does sessions in a hyperbaric chamber, gets inside an infrared sauna.
正规医生做不到，所以她开始尝试人们为这些症状尝试的所有其他治疗方法——而且有很多。她进行了高压氧舱疗程，进了红外线桑拿房。
I tried this, like, elimination diet, where all I could eat was, like, grapefruit and goat cheese and oatmeal. I tried, like, a very intense regimen of Chinese herbs that a doctor in New York City invented and manufactured himself. But at every turn, you're like, am I being preyed upon? I'm spending so much money.
我尝试过这种“排除饮食法”，我只能吃葡萄柚、山羊奶酪和燕麦片。我还尝试了一种非常强烈的中国草药疗法，那是一位纽约医生自己发明并制造的。但每走一步，你都会想，我是在被猎食吗？我花了很多钱。
And this drags on for years. She's floating in this unpleasant vortex, an interstellar medical space where nobody's got answers. Things get so bad that she leaves her job in the middle of her contract, because it was too hard to make it through the day. She moves from New York to the Arizona desert, thinking that might help. And now it's five years since her symptoms first appeared.
这拖了好几年。她漂浮在这个令人不适的漩涡中，一个没有人能给出答案的医学星际空间。情况变得非常糟糕，以至于她在合同期中途辞职了，因为很难坚持过每一天。她从纽约搬到了亚利桑那州的沙漠，认为那可能会有帮助。现在离她第一次出现症状已经过去五年了。
I was just looking down this road that looked really bleak. And this was around the time when I was working with a chronic disease life coach, who was starting to say things like, well, Ora, what would it be like if you never get better? Why don't we start thinking about that, like to have radical acceptance? And I felt very resistant to that, but teetering on the precipice of giving up.
我当时只是看着这条看起来非常黯淡的道路。那大约是在我与一位慢性病生活教练合作的时候，她开始说，嗯，奥拉，如果你永远好不了会怎样？我们为什么不开始思考这个问题，比如去进行“激进的接纳”？我对这感到非常抗拒，但也处于放弃的边缘。
It was at this point that Ora's mom heard about somebody in Ora's situation who supposedly got cured and sent Ora to that doctor. And he suggested a treatment where he was going to put a common product-- this is something you get at any drugstore for cheap-- into her veins with an IV.
就在这时，奥拉的妈妈听说了一位和奥拉处境相似的人据称被治愈了，于是把奥拉送到了那位医生那里。他建议了一种治疗方法，要把一种普通产品——在任何药店都能廉价买到的东西——通过静脉注射输入她的血管。
I am not going to tell you what this product is because this is so unproven. The Centers for Disease Control has said there is no evidence that this works. In fact, this is a toxin. It would do equal damage to healthy and diseased cells. The Infectious Diseases Society of America has warned against trying this because the dangers outweigh these utterly unproven benefits. But this doctor--
我不会告诉你这种产品是什么，因为它太未经证实了。美国疾病控制与预防中心曾表示，没有证据表明它有效。事实上，这是一种毒素。它会对健康细胞和病变细胞造成同样的伤害。美国传染病协会曾警告不要尝试这种方法，因为风险远大于这些完全未经证实的收益。但是这位医生——
He thought that would cure it, but he seems very confident. And his explanation for why I hadn't heard of this before was because it's so accessible and so cheap and so affordable, big pharma doesn't want you to have it.
他认为这能治愈，他显得非常有信心。对于我为什么以前没听说过这个，他的解释是因为它太容易获得、太便宜、太实惠了，大制药公司不想让你拥有它。
Now, when someone says an argument like that to you, are you the kind of person who's like, yes, I'm in because I hate big pharma, or are you the kind of person who's like, I don't know, that's what crazy people say?
现在，当有人对你提出这种论点时，你是那种会说“我加入，因为我讨厌大制药公司”的人，还是那种会说“我不知道，那是疯子才说的话”的人？
I'm both. It's like, I'm always open, but I'm also very aware of how crazy it sounds.
我两者都是。就像，我总是持开放态度，但我也非常清楚这听起来有多疯狂。
It did sound crazy to you?
这听起来确实很疯狂吗？
Yeah, I think anytime a medical doctor is telling you something that sounds like a conspiracy theory, it's warrant for concern.
是的，我认为任何时候当一位医学医生告诉你一些听起来像阴谋论的事情时，那都是值得担心的理由。
Yeah.
是的。
But at this point, I'm like-- I mean, I can't think clearly. I'm so tired. I'm so eager to move on with my life that I'm really feeling willing to try anything. And I think I didn't do as much research as one might imagine.
但到了这个地步，我心想——我是说，我无法清晰地思考。我太累了。我太渴望继续我的生活了，以至于我真的觉得愿意尝试任何事。而且我觉得我做的研究不像人们想象的那么多。
I did more research than her.
我做的研究比她多。
This is Ora's little sister, Aviva, joining the interview. And the way I heard about this story is that Aviva works here at the radio show, Aviva DeKornfeld. She'd watched her sister suffer for years and worried about her. But this treatment?
这是奥拉的妹妹阿维娃，加入到采访中。我听说这个故事是因为阿维娃就在这个广播节目工作，阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德。她看着姐姐受苦多年，为她担忧。但这种治疗？
I was very scared. I mean, I was really fixated on this article that I sent her about this woman who had died, who did the IV and then, within 36 hours, was dead. And I thought, doesn't seem worth it.
我非常害怕。我是说，我当时非常执着于我发给她的那篇文章，关于一个女人做了静脉注射，然后在36小时内就去世了。我想，这看起来不值得。
It's true. The danger of this particular treatment is that it might kill you with, again, no solid studies showing that it works.
确实。这种特殊治疗的危险在于它可能会要了你的命，而且再次重申，没有可靠的研究表明它有效。
And when you showed that to her, what did she say?
当你把那个拿给她看时，她说什么了？
She was freaked out by it, obviously, but was just kind of like, the current state and how I feel also isn't sustainable. My preference would be to have a sister who is sick and alive, rather than a dead sister.
她显然被吓坏了，但只是觉得，目前的状态以及我的感觉也是不可持续的。我宁愿要一个生病但活着的姐姐，也不要一个死去的姐姐。
It's like you prefer to have a sister who is sick and alive than one who is dead. And it's-- not to be overly dramatic, I certainly didn't want to die, but I was like, I don't want to be the sister who's sick and alive. This really sucks. And my current state is just so unpleasant and so confused and exhausted, it was just reaching a point of this is not a way to really live. If there was a chance it could work, I wanted to try it.
就像你宁愿要一个生病但活着的姐姐，也不要一个已经去世的。而且这——并不是要过度戏剧化，我当然不想死，但我当时想，我不想成为那个生病但活着的姐姐。这真的很糟糕。我目前的状态是如此不愉快，如此困惑和疲惫，这真的到了一个地步，这不是真正的生活方式。如果有一丝可能奏效，我想试试。
This is like a Hail Mary pass.
这就像是一个“万福玛丽”传球（孤注一掷）。
Yeah, total Hail Mary.
是的，完全是孤注一掷。
So, fully knowing that this could kill her, she got the IVs, four of them over a few weeks. And this is not really the result I would have predicted. Her symptoms went away-- the ice cream scoop in her head, the brain fog, the fatigue, the achiness, all of it. Maybe the IV treatment had something to do with this. Maybe it didn't.
所以，在完全知道这可能会要了她的命的情况下，她接受了静脉注射，几周内做了四次。结果真的不是我能预测到的。她的症状消失了——脑子里的冰淇淋勺，脑雾，疲劳，疼痛，所有的这一切。也许静脉注射治疗与此有关。也许无关。
I've now spoken with three Lyme experts and researchers who could not explain this result. They said this is the kind of thing that you would want to do a proper scientific study on because the world is filled with things that seem to work in one isolated case and then really don't prove out.
我采访了三位莱姆病专家和研究人员，他们无法解释这个结果。他们说，这正是那种你想进行正式科学研究的事情，因为世界上充满了在个案中似乎有效，但最终无法证实的东西。
I also managed to reach Ora's doctor, and the one thing that he said to me in an email was that he was convinced that it was not the IV that ended her symptoms, but one of the other things that he tried with her. He'd given her other supplements and pills. And then he ghosted me without saying what that thing was that he thought worked, wouldn't reply to repeated emails and texts.
我也设法联系到了奥拉的医生，他在一封电子邮件中对我说的唯一一件事是，他坚信结束她症状的不是静脉注射，而是他尝试过的其他东西之一。他给了她其他补充剂和药丸。然后他就不理我了，也没说他认为有效的那个东西是什么，对我的反复邮件和短信不予回复。
And Ora, when she looks back on it now, she thinks it's kind of nuts. She's glad she was cured, for sure, but to be that desperate that you feel like you have no other choice so you throw everything you have into something that not only seems unlikely to succeed sometimes is genuinely terrifying. That is not a place anybody ever wants to be, like this IV treatment.
现在回想起来，奥拉觉得这有点疯狂。她当然很高兴自己被治愈了，但绝望到觉得自己别无选择，以至于把一切都押在一种不仅看起来不太可能成功、有时甚至让人真正感到恐惧的事情上。那不是任何人想待的地方，就像这种静脉注射治疗一样。
It doesn't seem like a good idea. You can't look back on it and be like, well, given the information we had at the time, we made the best decision we could. It's like, no, that was a bad idea. And so if it turns out bad, then it's like, you have no one to blame but yourself. But if it turns out good-- and I guess that's what the Hail Mary is, is a bad idea that has the potential to work.
这看起来不是个好主意。你不能回过头来看待它时说，好吧，鉴于当时我们掌握的信息，我们做了能做的最好决定。这就像是，不，那是坏主意。所以如果结果不好，那就是你只能怪自己。但如果结果好了——我猜这就是孤注一掷的意义，一个有潜力奏效的坏主意。
Today on our program, people in bad situations with no other options going for crazy long shots they hope against hope are going to fix the impossible situations they found themselves in. Our entire episode today, my friends, happens in the fourth quarter, seconds left in the game, after coming from 29 points behind, far, far from the basket, throwing a ball that really looks like it's going to be short. When does that ever work out?
今天我们的节目，关注的是在没有其他选择的糟糕处境下，为了希望能修补那些陷入困境的局面，而去孤注一掷的人们。我的朋友们，我们今天的整期节目都发生在第四节，比赛还剩几秒，在落后29分之后，距离篮筐很远，投出的球看起来真的很像是要投短了。那什么时候会成功呢？
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
This American Life, Act 1, 12 Weeks Notice. So some jobs, the entire premise of the job is that every day, you're going to go up against impossible odds, on a mission that is probably not going to succeed. And then, you have to go to work, throw yourself into it, try to make it happen, day after day. There's a new series by our coworkers at Serial about people like that. It's about defense attorneys who work with death row inmates.
《美国生活》，第一幕，12周通知。有些工作，其整个前提就是你每天都要面对不可能的困难，执行一项很可能不会成功的任务。然后，你必须去上班，全身心投入，尝试让它实现，日复一日。我们的同事在《Serial》做了一个关于这类人的新系列。它是关于那些为死囚辩护的辩护律师。
In Texas, where this particular story takes place, these kinds of appeals to get people off death row fail 94% of the time. And hearing this series, for all the news stories and movies that I've seen about lawyers in that job, it showed sides of it that really surprised me. I don't think I really got some things about the people who do that job and what that job is, until I heard this series.
在得克萨斯州，也就是这个特殊故事发生的地方，这类让人们脱离死囚牢房的上诉有94%的几率会失败。听这个系列节目时，尽管我见过许多关于律师从事这项工作的纪录片和电影，但它展现了一些让我真正感到惊讶的一面。直到听了这个系列，我才真正理解那些从事这项工作的人以及这份工作究竟意味着什么。
And so they allowed us to pull a few scenes from the first two episodes to play for you here so you can get a sense of this. We'll start at the top of the show. Here's how they open the series. Maurice Chammah of the Marshall Project is the host.
因此，他们允许我们从前两集中提取一些片段在这里播放，让大家感受一下。我们将从节目开头开始。这就是他们开篇的方式。马歇尔项目（The Marshall Project）的莫里斯·查马（Maurice Chammah）是主持人。
In the fall of 2024, a criminal defense lawyer got the kind of phone call that most lawyers can only dream about. It concerned a client of his, a guy named David Wood, one of Texas's most notorious serial killers. He was sitting on death row, months away from his execution.
2024年秋天，一位刑事辩护律师接到了大多数律师梦寐以求的那种电话。它涉及他的一位客户，一个名叫大卫·伍德的人，他是得克萨斯州最臭名昭著的连环杀手之一。他当时坐在死囚牢房里，离处决还有几个月。
I would like to discuss with you something about David Wood. While I don't condone what has happened in that case, the fact is I don't like--
我想和你讨论一些关于大卫·伍德的事情。虽然我不宽恕那个案件中发生的事情，但事实是我不喜欢——
The man on the phone, George Hall, thought something corrupt had gone down in David Wood's trial. It had happened more than 30 years ago, but for 30 years, he'd said nothing, mostly because he was afraid to. For those 30 years he'd been on parole, he worried if he aggravated the authorities, they might find some way to send him back to prison. But now his parole had ended, and George Hall was ready to tell his story, which he'd eventually put into a sworn declaration. That story goes like this.
打电话的人乔治·霍尔认为大卫·伍德的审判中存在腐败。那是30多年前发生的事，但30年来他什么都没说，主要是因为他害怕。在那30年里他一直处于假释期，他担心如果激怒了当局，他们可能会找到某种方式把他送回监狱。但现在他的假释期结束了，乔治·霍尔准备讲述他的故事，他最终将其写入了一份宣誓声明。那个故事是这样的。
Back in the late '80s, George Hall and David Wood were locked up together at the Eastham Unit in Texas. George Hall was in for murder. David Wood was in for rape. They weren't particularly close. David Wood was quiet, didn't talk much, but when he did, George says, it was mainly to complain about how the police in his hometown of El Paso were harassing him, investigating him for a series of murders.
回到80年代末，乔治·霍尔和大卫·伍德一起被关在得克萨斯州的伊斯特姆监狱。乔治·霍尔因谋杀入狱。大卫·伍德因强奸入狱。他们关系并不特别亲近。大卫·伍德很安静，话不多，但乔治说，当他说话时，主要是抱怨他家乡埃尔帕索的警察如何骚扰他，调查他参与的一系列谋杀案。
Basically, what he said was El Paso was trying to pin it on him.
基本上，他说的是埃尔帕索警方试图把罪名扣在他头上。
David Wood insisted he had nothing to do with those murders. George thought, maybe he didn't, maybe he did. Either way, he didn't really care. Eventually, George and David Wood were separated, moved to different facilities hundreds of miles apart. One day, George says, he's in the prison library, ready to go to lunch, when two officers come in and tell him to pack his stuff.
大卫·伍德坚称他与那些谋杀案无关。乔治想，也许他没有，也许他有。不管怎样，他真的不在乎。最终，乔治和大卫·伍德被分开了，搬到了相隔数百英里的不同设施。乔治说，有一天，他正在监狱图书馆准备去吃午饭，两名警官走进来让他收拾东西。
I said, well, where am I going? They wouldn't tell me. So next thing I know, I'm on a bus ride down to El Paso.
我说，好吧，我要去哪儿？他们不肯告诉我。所以接下来我知道的是，我坐上一辆巴士去了埃尔帕索。
A few hours later, George finds himself in a holding cell in the El Paso County Jail. Two other guys join him in there. George recognizes them both as guys who had celled with David Wood. And one of them says to the group, they have an opportunity. They can all get money maybe, or less prison time. All they have to do is snitch on David Wood. Soon enough, they're escorted out of the cell and into a car, and George says, that's when the cops start rolling out the red carpet.
几个小时后，乔治发现自己被关在埃尔帕索县监狱的一个拘留室里。另外两个人加入了他的行列。乔治认出他们俩都曾和大卫·伍德关在一起。其中一个人对大家说，他们有一个机会。他们都有机会赚钱或者减少刑期。他们所要做的就是举报大卫·伍德。没过多久，他们被带出牢房上了车，乔治说，就在那时，警察开始铺设“红地毯”。
They give us the tour, a scenic drive up the mountainside, a look across the Rio Grande, look into old Mexico and this and that and whatever. And I'm sitting there, thinking to myself, we're not handcuffed. What if we jump out and run?
他们带我们参观，开车兜风上山，看一眼格兰德河，看一眼老墨西哥之类的。我坐在那里，心想，我们没戴手铐。如果我们跳下车逃跑怎么办？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What are they going to do then, you know?
他们能怎么办呢？
But he sits tight. George says they're taken to a hamburger joint for lunch and then, ultimately, to a police station. The guys are offered coffee, snacks, cigarettes, and then they're ushered into a room with detectives.
但他还是坐着没动。乔治说他们被带到一家汉堡店吃午饭，最终被带到了警察局。这些人被招待了咖啡、零食、香烟，然后被带进了一个与侦探谈话的房间。
Of course, they got files everywhere. They got David Woods's name plastered all over everything. They got arrows and lines going to this, this, dates wrote down. Files are sitting there. They start handing us files. Look at this. We got this on him. We got this on him. He did this. We know this, this, this, this, and going through all facts and stuff there, this narrative-driven shit. And you're reading what they got. And then after that, they go, you know anything? Well, I don't know a goddamn thing. All they had to do is ask me at the prison unit. I was madder than shit about it.
当然，他们到处都是档案。大卫·伍德的名字被贴满了所有地方。他们有指向这个那个的箭头和线条，写下的日期。档案就在那里。他们开始把档案递给我们。看看这个。我们掌握了他的这个证据。掌握了他的那个。他做了这个。我们知道这个这个这个，过一遍事实之类的，这种充满叙事的垃圾。你读着他们掌握的内容。然后在那之后，他们问，你知道什么吗？好吧，我什么都不知道。他们当初在监狱单位问我就行了。我对此非常生气。
As for the other two guys--
至于另外两个人——
They go back. They're talking to each other, but it's in a real low tone. And they basically don't even want to talk to me about nothing. So I knew to myself right then and there, they're going to say whatever they want them to say.
他们回去了。他们互相交谈，但语气非常低沉。他们基本上甚至不想和我谈论任何事情。所以我当时就知道，他们打算说出警察想让他们说的任何话。
They're going to tell the police that David Wood confessed to multiple murders. But George is sure these guys don't actually know anything about David Wood. He would have heard about it already. Plus, he knows they're not above lying.
他们将告诉警方大卫·伍德承认犯下了多起谋杀案。但乔治肯定这些人根本不知道关于大卫·伍德的任何事。他早就应该听说过了。此外，他知道他们不是那种不撒谎的人。
George returns to prison. Not long after, he writes to an El Paso prosecutor about, quote, "improprieties that I am aware of." He says he knows the informants are fabricating their stories. The prosecutor never writes back, but the letter does make its way into David Wood's case file.
乔治回到监狱。没过多久，他写信给埃尔帕索的一位检察官，引用了“我所知道的不当行为”。他说他知道那些线人是在捏造故事。检察官从未回信，但那封信最终进入了大卫·伍德的案卷。
Eventually, David Wood does go on trial for the murders. George is never called to testify, but the two other guys become the star witnesses for the prosecution. The jury convicts David Wood, and he's sentenced to death. Court documents show that after the trial, one of the informants received $13,000 in reward money. The other got his own capital murder charge dropped.
最终，大卫·伍德因谋杀案受审。乔治从未被传唤作证，但另外两人成为了控方的核心证人。陪审团判定大卫·伍德有罪，他被判处死刑。法庭文件显示，审判结束后，其中一名线人获得了1.3万美元的奖金。另一人则撤销了他自己的资本谋杀指控。
I identified more than a dozen officers, detectives, and supervisors who were involved in David Wood's case. I wanted to ask them about George Hall. Some were dead, one had dementia, one hung up on me, and others never responded.
我确认了十几名参与大卫·伍德案件的警官、侦探和主管。我想问他们关于乔治·霍尔的事。有些人死了，一个患有痴呆症，一个挂断了我的电话，其他人从未回应。
But the one detective who did speak to me extensively about the case called George's whole story, quote, "preposterous." George and the two others were brought in together and interviewed by the El Paso Police. That's documented in court records. But the detective said he couldn't imagine his colleagues taking prisoners out for a joyride and showing them case materials in order to get them to snitch.
但唯一一位和我详细谈论此案的侦探称乔治的整个故事是“荒谬的”。乔治和另外两人确实被带到一起，接受了埃尔帕索警方的采访。这在法庭记录中有记载。但这位侦探说他无法想象他的同事会带囚犯出去兜风，并向他们展示案件材料以让他们举报。
For more than 30 years after David Wood's trial, George kept tabs on the case, googled it from time to time. And in 2024, George saw that David Wood was scheduled for execution, and George was finally off parole, so if he was going to speak up, it was now or never.
在大卫·伍德受审后的30多年里，乔治一直留意着这个案子，偶尔会在谷歌上搜索它。2024年，乔治看到大卫·伍德被安排执行死刑，而乔治终于结束了假释，所以如果他要说出来，就是现在或永远没机会了。
I don't know if it's going to make a difference whether he gets executed or not. That's not the question. That's not what I got to live with. What I have to live with is, can I live with myself, knowing that I know two people fabricated testimony to get a guy executed, and I don't say anything about it?
我不知道他是否会被处决是否有任何区别。那不是问题。那不是我要与之共处的问题。我要与之共处的是，我知道有人捏造了证词来处决一个人，而我却什么都不说，我能问心无愧吗？
Not long after George Hall called David Wood's lawyer, David Wood's lawyer emailed me, asking me to write about the case. I wasn't surprised. I'm a journalist at a nonprofit called the Marshall Project, where we cover the criminal justice system. I'm the death penalty guy on staff, as gloomy as that sounds. But I was surprised by who was asking-- Greg Wiercioch.
在乔治·霍尔给大卫·伍德的律师打电话后不久，大卫·伍德的律师给我发了邮件，让我写写这个案子。我并不惊讶。我是在一家名为“马歇尔项目”的非营利机构工作的记者，我们报道刑事司法系统。我是员工中的死刑报道专家，听起来很阴沉。但我对提出请求的人感到惊讶——格雷格·维尔奇奥奇。
I know Greg Wiercioch as a big deal in capital defense work. He's been defending people on death row for decades, and he even stopped one execution by winning at the Supreme Court. I'd asked him for an interview years ago for a book I was writing on the death penalty. He said no. He rarely spoke to reporters.
我知道格雷格·维尔奇奥奇是死刑辩护领域的大人物。他几十年来一直在为死囚辩护，甚至通过在最高法院胜诉阻止了一次处决。多年前，我为我写的一本关于死刑的书向他请求采访。他说不。他很少对记者说话。
But now here he was in my inbox. His email was polite and panicky. David Wood's execution date was only 17 weeks away. He wanted me to write about the case and all the problems he saw with it. I was pretty skeptical. I did the hard-hitting research of reading the Wikipedia page about David Wood and, woof, six women and girls, one as young as 14, killed and buried in the desert outside of El Paso. David Wood even got one of those spooky serial killer nicknames, the Desert Killer.
但现在他出现在我的收件箱里。他的邮件礼貌而恐慌。离大卫·伍德的执行日期只有17周了。他希望我写写这个案子以及他所看到的所有问题。我非常怀疑。我做了艰苦的调查，阅读了大卫·伍德的维基百科页面，哇，六名女性和女孩，其中一名年仅14岁，被杀害并埋在埃尔帕索城外的沙漠里。大卫·伍德甚至还得到了一个那种诡异的连环杀手绰号，沙漠杀手。
Greg wrote to me that David Wood was innocent, that he didn't commit any of these murders. And sure, I did find George Hall's story compelling, but even if those informants were lying at the trial, that doesn't mean David Wood didn't do it. Plus, in order to do the story Greg was pitching, I'd have to reinvestigate it from scratch, all six murders in a matter of weeks. That sounded impossible.
格雷格写信给我说大卫·伍德是无辜的，他没有犯下这些谋杀案中的任何一起。当然，我确实觉得乔治·霍尔的故事令人信服，但即使那些线人在审判中撒谎，也不意味着大卫·伍德没做过。此外，为了做格雷格推销的故事，我必须从头开始重新调查，在几周内调查所有六起谋杀案。这听起来不可能。
But I was curious about what Greg was up to, his overall project, trying to sow enough doubt at the last minute in order to save his client's life. I'd seen executions get stayed for procedural claims about execution methods or a defendant's mental fitness. But this wasn't just a claim about an unfair trial. Greg was saying David Wood didn't do it at all, and now, somehow, he's supposed to prove that in a few months.
但我很好奇格雷格在做什么，他的整个项目，试图在最后一刻播下足够的怀疑，以挽救他客户的生命。我见过死刑因为关于执行方法或被告心理状况的程序性主张而被暂缓。但这不仅仅是一个关于审判不公的主张。格雷格说大卫·伍德根本没做过，而现在，不知何故，他要在几个月内证明这一点。
So I told Greg, I'm not going to do the big feature story on David Wood you're imagining. But what if I follow you around, be there with a microphone as you strategize with your team, hunt for witnesses, and try to persuade people of David Wood's innocence with the clock ticking? Greg had a million reasons to say no. I'm still kind of shocked that he said yes.
所以我告诉格雷格，我不会写你想象中的那种关于大卫·伍德的大专题报道。但如果我跟踪你，带着麦克风和你一起与你的团队制定策略、寻找证人，并在时间紧迫的情况下试图说服人们相信大卫·伍德的无辜呢？格雷格有一百万个理由拒绝。我到现在还很惊讶他答应了。
So that's the premise. Maurice is going to follow this defense team. And before we get to some of what he witnesses doing that, we should run through the evidence against David Wood in this murder conviction.
所以这就是前提。莫里斯将跟随这个辩护团队。在我们讨论他所见证的一些行动之前，我们应该过一遍大卫·伍德在这起谋杀定罪中的证据。
Maurice, thank you for talking me through this right now.
莫里斯，谢谢你现在为我梳理这些。
Yeah, thanks for having me here.
是的，谢谢邀请我。
Just a quick heads up for listeners that these crimes are pretty awful and might not be right for every listener or for children to listen to. Maurice, let's just run through it. How solid was the evidence that got David Wood the death penalty?
给听众一个简单的提醒，这些罪行非常可怕，可能不适合每一位听众，也不适合儿童收听。莫里斯，我们快速过一遍。大卫·伍德被判处死刑的证据有多扎实？
So the person who really walked us through the evidence was a detective who worked on the case. His name is John Guerrero. He was with the El Paso Police Department, and he's retired now. And he invited my Serial producer, Alvin Melathe, and I to his house in El Paso. He introduced himself as Johnny. It's one of the biggest cases of his career, and he seemed to like talking about it.
那么，真正带我们梳理证据的人是一位参与此案的侦探。他的名字叫约翰·格雷罗。他曾在埃尔帕索警察局工作，现在退休了。他邀请我和我的《Serial》制片人阿尔文·梅拉特到他埃尔帕索的家里。他自我介绍叫约翰尼。这是他职业生涯中最大的案件之一，他似乎很喜欢谈论它。
You can ask me, is there any doubt in your mind that this is the man that committed this heinous crimes against these little girls? None whatsoever. None. None.
你可以问我，你心中是否有任何怀疑这个人是犯下这些对小女孩的滔天罪行的人吗？完全没有。一点也没有。没有。
So this begins in the summer of 1987, and there are two county employees working in the desert outside of El Paso. And Johnny says they saw a leg sticking out of the sand. The police checked it out, and they found out that it was a woman named Rosa Maria Casio. She was in her 20s.
所以这一切始于1987年的夏天，有两名县政府雇员在埃尔帕索城外的沙漠工作。约翰尼说他们看到一只腿从沙子里露出来。警方进行了调查，发现那是一名名叫罗莎·玛丽亚·卡西奥的女性。她20多岁。
And then they searched the area around her, and pretty quickly, they find a second body about 50 feet away. It's a woman named Karen Baker. She's 20, and she's a mother of three young children. And then over the next few months, they find a total of six bodies in this area of the desert. Two of the victims are girls in middle school, and then their ages run up into their early 20s.
然后他们搜查了她周围的区域，很快就在大约50英尺外发现了第二具尸体。那是一名名叫凯伦·贝克的女性。她20岁，是三个年幼孩子的母亲。然后在接下来的几个月里，他们在沙漠的这个区域总共发现了六具尸体。受害者中有两名是初中女生，其余的年龄上升到20岁出头。
Ugh, middle school kids.
噢，初中的孩子。
I know. It's really-- it's awful. The detail that really stuck out to me was that they could identify the girl who'd been in eighth grade in part because they found her T-shirt where all the other kids had signed their names on the last day of school. And--
我知道。这真的很——这太糟糕了。那个让我印象深刻的细节是，他们之所以能确认那个八年级女孩的身份，部分原因是因为他们找到了她的T恤，上面签满了所有其他孩子在毕业那天留下的名字。而且——
Ugh.
噢。
--it turns out that that girl's mother becomes a real leading force in this case, and she pushes Johnny to see all of these murders as connected, first of all, and then to go talk to other middle school kids to try to get clues or tips from them about who might have done it.
——事实证明，那个女孩的母亲成为了此案真正的领导力量，她首先推动约翰尼将所有这些谋杀案联系起来，然后去和其他中学生交谈，试图从他们那里得到线索或提示，了解可能是谁做的。
And in fact, they do get clues. Let's play a little bit from the podcast of where you get into that.
事实上，他们确实得到了线索。让我们播放一小段你在播客中深入探讨的内容。
We started getting information from several people about this white guy that was going around in a beige truck and also in a motorcycle.
我们开始从几个人那里得到关于这个开着米色卡车和摩托车的白人男子的信息。
El Paso is majority Hispanic, so this detail, a white guy, stood out to Johnny. The kids say this guy was always around.
埃尔帕索大部分是西班牙裔，所以“白人男子”这个细节引起了约翰尼的注意。孩子们说这个家伙总是在附近。
Giving weeds to them and buying them beer and that kind of stuff. And then, also, we were told that he was real focused on these young girls, real young girls, 15, 16-year-old little girls. And I don't remember who it was, but somebody gave us this nickname, Skeeter.
给他们杂草（大麻），给他们买啤酒之类的。然后，我们还被告知他非常专注于这些年轻女孩，非常年轻的女孩，15、16岁的小女孩。我不记得是谁了，但有人给了我们这个绰号，斯基特（Skeeter）。
In old tapes from this investigation, you hear this name come up a lot, Skeeter.
在这个调查的老录音中，你会听到这个名字出现很多次，斯基特。
Did you ever hear any of the kids mention a guy by the name of Skeeter that had offered them some marijuana or something like that?
你有没有听说过任何孩子提到过一个叫斯基特的人给他们提供过大麻之类的东西？
You knew him by a nickname?
你知道他的绰号吗？
By Skeeter.
叫斯基特。
OK, how long had you known him?
好的，你认识他多久了？
And then we started asking people about this guy, Skeeter, Skeeter, Skeeter.
然后我们开始询问人们关于这个叫斯基特的人，斯基特，斯基特。
A Skeeter or a Scooter?
是斯基特还是斯库特？
Skeeter. That was that guy in the truck.
斯基特。就是那个开卡车的家伙。
That was the guy in the truck?
那个开卡车的？
Yeah.
是的。
Somebody said, well, Skeeter is a guy that just got out of prison.
有人说，嗯，斯基特是一个刚出狱的人。
Skeeter is who?
斯基特是谁？
And his name is--
他的名字是——
David Wood, I guess.
大卫·伍德，我想。
--David Wood. Of course, we run his name.
——大卫·伍德。当然，我们查了他的名字。
The mechanics of how Skeeter and David Wood get linked are hazy. In the recordings I listened to, most of the kids had no idea who Skeeter was. And the ones who say Skeeter was David Wood, it's not clear if they put that together themselves or if they were repeating the connection that the cops made.
斯基特和大卫·伍德是如何联系起来的，细节很模糊。在我听的录音中，大多数孩子根本不知道斯基特是谁。而那些说斯基特就是大卫·伍德的人，不清楚是他们自己拼凑出来的，还是在重复警察建立的联系。
In any case, when Johnny learns more about David Wood's criminal record, he discovers a rap sheet that's long and egregious, multiple sexual crimes against girls, one as young as 12. And the timeline tracks. David Wood had been released from prison less than a month before the first of these victims disappeared.
无论如何，当约翰尼了解到更多关于大卫·伍德的犯罪记录时，他发现了一份长且令人震惊的犯罪记录，针对女孩的多项性犯罪，一名受害者甚至年仅12岁。时间线也吻合。大卫·伍德在第一名受害者失踪前不到一个月刚出狱。
So I mean, right away, the antennas go up. The red lights start blinking and what have you, you know?
所以我说，立刻，天线就竖起来了。红灯开始闪烁之类的，你懂的，对吧？
OK, so that is what makes David Wood Johnny's prime suspect. But Maurice, as you say in the show, just having a nickname and a history of crimes, even very disturbing crimes, that is actually not enough to put him away for six murders. They also get the two jailhouse witnesses that you talked about in the show's opening. And then there's one bit of physical evidence that connects David Wood to the crime.
好的，这就是大卫·伍德成为约翰尼主要嫌疑人的原因。但莫里斯，正如你在节目中所说，仅仅有一个绰号和一段犯罪史，甚至是令人不安的犯罪史，实际上不足以将他因六起谋杀案而定罪。他们还获得了你在节目开头谈到的两名监狱证人。此外还有一点物证将大卫·伍德与罪行联系起来。
Yeah, it was surprising to me that there was only one bit of physical evidence. It's a set of orange fibers, probably from a blanket. And these are threads that came from David Wood's vacuum cleaner, like the bag in his vacuum cleaner. And then they were also found with one of the victims' bodies in the desert.
是的，让我惊讶的是只有一点物证。那是一套橙色的纤维，可能来自毯子。这些线头来自大卫·伍德的吸尘器，就像他吸尘器里的袋子。然后它们也在沙漠里受害者的尸体之一旁边被发现了。
And then the other big thing that Johnny's got-- and this is probably the most substantial thing that connects Wood to these murders-- is this woman named Judith Kelling. Tell her story.
然后约翰尼掌握的另一件大事——这可能是将伍德与这些谋杀案联系起来的最重要的事情——就是这个叫朱迪思·凯林的女人。讲讲她的故事。
Judith Kelling was a sex worker in El Paso in the '80s, and she's deceased now, but she came forward and did a recorded interview with Johnny.
朱迪思·凯林是80年代埃尔帕索的一名性工作者，她现在已经去世了，但她站出来并接受了约翰尼的录音采访。
Today's date is Monday, November the 16th, 1987.
今天是1987年11月16日，星期一。
She came forward shortly after some of the women were found in the desert. And she said she'd been hitchhiking, and a white guy picked her up with his truck. And he wouldn't take her to where she wanted to go, but instead invited her to do cocaine with him out in the desert. So he drives her out there and pulls out a shovel and also some rope.
她在沙漠中发现其中一些女性尸体后不久就站了出来。她说她当时在搭便车，一个白人男子用卡车搭了她。他没有带她去她想去的地方，而是邀请她去沙漠里和他一起吸食可卡因。于是他开车把她带到那里，拿出了一把铲子还有一根绳子。
So this is from her interview.
这是她的采访内容。
And he took the shovel, and he started digging. And he came back. He got the blanket, and he told me-- he took me-- he made me get out the truck. I didn't want to. I told him, just take me back. He kept calling me a bitch. He goes, don't turn around, bitch. And I was getting panicky and scared because I thought he was going to try something with me.
他拿起铲子开始挖掘。然后他回来了。他拿了毯子，告诉我——他带我——他强迫我下卡车。我不想。我告诉他，直接送我回去。他一直叫我婊子。他说，别回头，婊子。我开始感到恐慌和害怕，因为我想他要对我做些什么。
Judith Kelling says that he tied her up and raped her, and there are a lot of creepy details, like he kept telling her to say that she was 14 years old. And then he hears some voices nearby and gets spooked, and he leaves her out in the middle of the desert to find her own way home.
朱迪思·凯林说他把她绑起来并强奸了她，而且有很多令人毛骨悚然的细节，比如他一直让她说她今年14岁。然后他听到附近有声音，被吓到了，就把她扔在沙漠中间让她自己找路回家。
The police give Judith a photo lineup, and she identifies David Wood as the guy. And she takes the police to where she was raped, and Johnny tells me that it's about 50 yards from where the murder victims were found.
警方给朱迪思看了照片排队，她指认大卫·伍德就是那个人。她带警察去了她被强奸的地方，约翰尼告诉我，那里距离发现谋杀受害者的位置大约50码。
And then, as you explained in the show, the police arrest Wood for the rape. He denies it, but he's convicted, and he goes to prison. And then, with him in prison, Johnny tries to connect him to the six murders.
然后，正如你在节目中所解释的，警方因强奸罪逮捕了伍德。他否认了，但他被定罪，进了监狱。然后，在他入狱后，约翰尼试图将他与六起谋杀案联系起来。
Yeah, and it takes a long time. But the jury is convinced, and they only deliberate for, like, 90 minutes before sentencing him to death.
是的，花了很长时间。但陪审团确信了，他们只讨论了大约90分钟就判处他死刑。
And so in your podcast, after you explain all that background, then your series really gets going, and you really get into the meat of it. And we follow the defense attorneys, led by Greg Wiercioch, as they try all kinds of different tactics and meet with all sorts of people to try to stop David Wood's execution.
所以在你的播客中，在你解释了所有背景之后，你的系列节目真正开始了，你真正进入了核心内容。我们跟随以格雷格·维尔奇奥奇为首的辩护律师，因为他们尝试了各种不同的策略，并与各种各样的人会面，试图阻止大卫·伍德的处决。
They have just 12 weeks. They go to a district attorney. They go to a TV news person. They hear about somebody who thinks their dad may have committed at least some of the six murders, and they have to decide if that is worth running down. I have to say, I was really surprised at how many different roads they could go down and had to choose between.
他们只有12周的时间。他们去找地区检察官。他们去找电视新闻记者。他们听说有一个人认为他们的父亲可能犯下了至少六起谋杀案中的一些，他们必须决定是否值得追查下去。我必须说，我真的很惊讶他们可以走这么多不同的路，而且必须在其中做出选择。
Yeah, he had a lot of them to choose between. Greg actually got the original list of police suspects, and there were 36 of them on it. And some of them did seem promising. So there was one man who failed a polygraph test about the murders, which I know those are unreliable, but he did fail it. So Greg's team runs that one down, and Alvin and I had to actually knock on some of these people's doors, too, which we describe in the show.
是的，他有很多选择。格雷格实际上拿到了最初的警方嫌疑人名单，上面有36个人。其中一些确实看起来有希望。有一个人没能通过关于谋杀案的测谎仪测试，我知道那些是不可靠的，但他确实没通过。所以格雷格的团队追查了那一条，阿尔文和我也确实不得不敲开其中一些人的门，我们在节目中描述过。
Basically, Greg's theory on this case is that the cops had tunnel vision. They were under all this pressure to solve the case. The victims' families were demonstrating in public. And so they took every bit of evidence and massaged it to fit David Wood or discarded it if it fit someone else.
基本上，格雷格对这个案子的理论是警察有隧道视野。他们承受着解决此案的所有压力。受害者的家属在公开场合示威。所以他们拿走了每一份证据，对其进行润色以符合大卫·伍德的情况，或者如果符合其他人就将其丢弃。
And so, with all that in mind, let's just pick up with your show at this scene that happens in your second episode. Greg has just been to the courthouse to reexamine some of the physical evidence in the trial, the orange fibers. It is 50 days before David Wood's execution is scheduled to take place.
所以，考虑到所有这些，让我们从你的节目在第二集中发生的那个场景开始接上。格雷格刚从法院出来，重新检查了审判中的一些物证，即橙色纤维。距离大卫·伍德预定的处决还有50天。
On the way out of the courthouse, Greg says he wants to grab one more thing from a clerk. He asks for any and all criminal records related to a guy named Michael Plyler. This is a new name to me. It wasn't on the El Paso PD's list of 36 suspects.
在走出法院的路上，格雷格说他想从办事员那里再拿一件东西。他要求索取任何和所有关于一个叫迈克尔·普莱勒的人的犯罪记录。这是一个对我来说的新名字。它不在埃尔帕索警察局的36名嫌疑人名单上。
But the other night, Greg came across Plyler's name in old state records, along with a picture of a truck, which looked a lot like David Wood's truck. So Greg wondered, could this all be a case of mistaken identity? He wants to look through Plyler's criminal files to see if there's anything in there that might tie him to the case beyond the truck, like if he went by the nickname Skeeter.
但前几天晚上，格雷格在旧的州记录中发现了普莱勒的名字，还有一张卡车的照片，看起来和大卫·伍德的卡车很像。所以格雷格想，这会不会是一起身份误认案件？他想查看普莱勒的犯罪档案，看看里面是否有任何东西可能将他与案件联系起来，超越那辆卡车，比如他是否用过“斯基特”这个绰号。
Because Skeeter is this nickname that keeps popping up throughout the case as David Wood, but David Wood's never used that as a nickname. So it seems a bit odd that that would be a name he would be giving to people.
因为斯基特这个绰号在整个案件中一直被当作大卫·伍德，但大卫·伍德从来没用过这个绰号。所以他会给别人起这个名字似乎有点奇怪。
This depends on believing David Wood about the nickname, which Greg does. But either way, this Plyler deep dive seems to me like a real long shot. And it reminds me of a criticism I've heard a lot, mostly from prosecutors and judges. They say, lawyers like Greg have years to do this stuff, but they wait until the last minute, so they can maximize the drama. I ask him about this.
这取决于是否相信大卫·伍德关于绰号的说法，格雷格相信。但无论如何，这个对普莱勒的深入挖掘对我来说看起来像是一个真正的长线希望（不太可能成功）。这让我想起我经常听到的批评，主要是来自检察官和法官。他们说，像格雷格这样的律师有多年时间来做这些事，但他们一直等到最后一刻，这样他们就能最大限度地增加戏剧性。我问了他这件事。
So these are files that you've had for a long time, and you're just now-- I guess, I wondered if this name had--
所以这些文件你已经持有很长时间了，你现在才——我猜，我想知道这个名字是否——
Oh.
哦。
--emerged--
——出现了——
Yeah.
是的。
--and something you just got or--
——是你刚拿到的东西还是——
No, yeah, but I've had it for a long time in the sense that it's buried in 12,000 pages of records. [CHUCKLES]
不，是的，但我持有它很长时间了，因为它埋在1.2万页的记录中。[笑声]
He says it's buried in 12,000 pages of records, his point being that, yes, he's technically had Michael Plyler's name for years, but he's been working solo for much of that time, so he's had to pick and choose what to focus on. But it's also true that Greg is incentivized to stretch this out as much as possible, to show up at court with new information right before the execution. That way, the judges will be so overwhelmed, they'll have to hit the pause button, and Greg's client gets to live another day.
他说它埋在1.2万页的记录中，他的意思确实是，从技术上讲他持有迈克尔·普莱勒的名字已经很多年了，但他大部分时间都是单独工作，所以他不得不挑选重点关注的内容。但这也是事实，格雷格有动力尽可能延长这个过程，在处决前夕带着新信息出现在法庭上。这样，法官们就会感到应接不暇，不得不按下暂停键，格雷格的客户就能多活一天。
In fact, Greg's already been accused pretty harshly of delaying David Wood's execution in all kinds of ways. In 2009, Wood was about to be put to death, and a day before it, Greg got them to delay by arguing that David Wood has an intellectual disability. The courts ultimately reject this appeal, but it takes five years for them to rule on it. Then they spend years arguing over evidence that was never DNA-tested. Last year, a judge, summarizing the last 15 years of this case, accused David's defense of a, quote, "pattern of piecemeal litigation and delay."
事实上，格雷格已经被相当严厉地指责用各种方式拖延大卫·伍德的处决。2009年，伍德即将被处死，在处决前一天，格雷格通过辩称大卫·伍德有智力障碍而将其延期。法院最终驳回了这一上诉，但他们花了五年时间才做出裁决。然后他们又花了多年时间争论从未经过DNA测试的证据。去年，一位法官在总结此案过去15年的情况时，指责大卫的辩护方存在“零碎诉讼和拖延的模式”。
Over those years, Greg has filed motions to replace prosecutors, to claim a judge had a conflict of interest, to test this or that bit of evidence. He lost all these arguments, but the judge's point was, this guy just throws spaghetti at the wall to see what sticks, and he does it one noodle at a time.
多年来，格雷格提交了撤换检察官的动议，声称法官存在利益冲突，要求测试这样或那样的证据。他输掉了所有这些论点，但法官的观点是，这家伙只是把意大利面扔在墙上看看哪一根能粘住，而且他是一根一根地扔。
Other lawyers get accused of the same things. There's a perception on the part of prosecutors and also lots of judges that lawyers like Greg are such extreme anti-death penalty zealots that they're willing to bend the rules, if not outright break them.
其他律师也被指责有同样的行为。在检察官和许多法官看来，像格雷格这样的律师是极端反死刑的狂热分子，以至于他们愿意弯曲规则，甚至完全打破它们。
Greg and I finish up at the courthouse around lunchtime. Before we head back to the hotel, he proposes we swing by someone's house first-- a woman he's been trying to talk to for some time now, Ramona Dismukes. Her importance as a witness is kind of questionable. She was best friends with a girl who disappeared back in 1987. A lot of people in El Paso assumed David Wood was responsible, but police never found evidence, and he wasn't convicted of it. It's the kind of witness I could imagine skipping, but Greg decides it's worth a try.
格雷格和我在午餐时间左右完成了法院的工作。在我们回到酒店之前，他建议我们先顺道去某人家里——一个他已经尝试联系一段时间的女人，拉莫娜·迪斯穆克斯。她作为证人的重要性有点令人怀疑。她是1987年失踪的一名女孩的最好朋友。埃尔帕索的许多人都认为大卫·伍德负责，但警方从未找到证据，他也没有被定罪。这是一种我可能会跳过的证人，但格雷格决定尝试一下。
We pull off the highway and drive up to this small house where a guy with a mohawk is hauling stuff out to a dumpster. Greg hops out of the car and talks to him. He comes back, looking defeated. But as we're pulling away, I see a woman in the rearview mirror.
我们驶离高速公路，开车来到这个小房子，一个留着莫霍克发型的家伙正在把东西搬进垃圾箱。格雷格跳下车和他交谈。他回来时显得很沮丧。但当我们开走时，我在后视镜里看到一个女人。
Yeah, let me see. Hi. How are you?
是的，让我看看。嗨。你好吗？
Greg leads the woman towards the car, and I roll down my window.
格雷格领着那个女人走向车，我摇下窗户。
What's your name? I'm sorry.
你叫什么名字？抱歉。
Oh, yeah, this is--
哦，是的，这是——
I'm Ramona Dismukes.
我是拉莫娜·迪斯穆克斯。
Everyone is half-interrupting each other. Ramona tells us the mohawk guy is actually her husband. She moved out of state and is just back to do renovations. She seems excited to talk to Greg, but says the house is too much of a mess to invite him in. She suggests another spot.
每个人都在半打断对方。拉莫娜告诉我们那个莫霍克发型的家伙实际上是她的丈夫。她搬到了外州，只是回来做翻新。她似乎很兴奋和格雷格交谈，但说房子太乱了，不能邀请他进去。她建议去另一个地方。
I mean, there's a Whataburger up the street, right around the corner.
我的意思是，街上有个Whataburger，就在拐角处，对吧？
OK.
好的。
And I can go there--
我可以去那里——
Your husband said you might have files and records still.
你丈夫说你可能还有文件和记录。
I still have all of the old articles. I have everything.
我还有所有的旧文章。我什么都有。
All right, to the left.
好的，向左转。
See you in a bit.
一会儿见。
Naomi and Alvin meet us at the Whataburger. As the only native Texan in this group, I feel obligated to say, Whataburger is a state institution, but it is not a great place to do an interview. There's loud music, soda fountains and fryers going, people coming in and out. Ramona blazes in, big, expressive face. Her hair is wild and curly, some of the layers dyed cherry red.
娜奥米和阿尔文在Whataburger和我们汇合。作为这群人中唯一的得克萨斯本地人，我感到有义务说，Whataburger是州立机构，但它不是进行采访的好地方。那里有嘈杂的音乐、苏打水机和油炸锅，人们进进出出。拉莫娜风风火火地冲进来，表情丰富。她的头发狂野卷曲，其中几层染成了樱桃红。
She slaps down this giant binder, very dusty, that says, "Mona's Articles"-- she also goes by Mona-- in cursive letters next to what looks like a cigarette burn. It's full of old newspaper clippings that leave flakes on the table. Apparently, all those years Greg was developing his theories of what really happened in 1987, Ramona was nursing her own.
她重重地拍下这个巨大的、非常多尘的活页夹，上面用草书写着“莫娜的文章”——她也叫莫娜——旁边看起来像是个烟头烫痕。里面全是旧报纸剪报，在桌子上留下了碎片。显然，在格雷格发展他关于1987年到底发生了什么理论的所有那些年里，拉莫娜也在酝酿她自己的理论。
El Paso is a pretty big city, but Ramona talked about it like a small town. David Wood, the police, the victims, their parents-- everybody knows everybody, as if somehow they all went to high school together. Even this Whataburger is relevant, in a way. Ramona tells us she got involved in this case because of her best friend, Cheryl Vasquez. When they were still teenagers, Cheryl married Ramona's brother, which made them best friends and sisters-in-law. And Cheryl--
埃尔帕索是个相当大的城市，但拉莫娜谈论起它来就像个小镇。大卫·伍德、警察、受害者、他们的父母——每个人都认识每个人，好像他们都一起上过高中一样。甚至这个Whataburger在某种程度上也是相关的。拉莫娜告诉我们，她卷入这个案子是因为她最好的朋友谢丽尔·瓦斯奎兹。当她们还是青少年时，谢丽尔嫁给了拉莫娜的兄弟，这使她们成为最好的朋友和嫂子。而谢丽尔——
She worked right here at this Whataburger. This is where she worked.
她就在这个Whataburger工作。这就是她工作的地方。
Wow.
哇。
When she went missing, she was working here. And she never even got her last check from this place because she was gone. But--
当她失踪时，她就在这里工作。她甚至没拿到在这个地方的最后一张支票，因为她不见了。但是——
Cheryl was 19 when she disappeared, the same summer as all the Desert Killer victims. When bodies started turning up in the desert, Ramona was worried that Cheryl was going to be one of them. She felt the cops weren't looking hard enough for her friend, so she enlisted her mom, and they decided to figure out what happened to Cheryl themselves. They knew Cheryl was last seen at this one Circle K convenience store. And so they came up with, frankly, a totally bonkers plan.
谢丽尔失踪时19岁，和“沙漠杀手”的所有受害者是同一个夏天。当沙漠里开始出现尸体时，拉莫娜很担心谢丽尔会是其中之一。她觉得警察没有为她的朋友做足够的寻找，所以她拉上了她的妈妈，她们决定自己弄清楚谢丽尔发生了什么。她们知道谢丽尔最后一次出现在这家Circle K便利店。于是她们想出了一个坦率地说完全疯狂的计划。
We started hanging out at that Circle K. And my mom was literally tricking me. She was like, go sit on that wall, and somebody's going to come and try to kidnap you. And I'll call the cops, and we'll get them and we'll know who it was. And I'm like, OK.
我们开始在那个Circle K徘徊。我妈简直是在骗我。她说，去坐在那堵墙上，会有人来试图绑架你。我会报警，我们会抓住他们，我们就会知道那是谁了。我说，好的。
Your mom like a real character from what I've--
你妈真是个有个性的人，从我所听到的来看——
Oh! She was feisty until the moment she died. She had me sit on that wall in little shorts, 17 years old, waiting to get me kidnapped. I'm like, thanks, Mom. But--
噢！她一直是个性十足，直到她去世的那一刻。她让我坐在那堵墙上穿着短裤，17岁，等着被绑架。我说，谢谢你，妈妈。但是——
By way of explanation, Ramona says that her mom was, quote, "German." The lawyers don't ask her to explain more. But as strange as the plan was, there was some logic to it. Ramona and Cheryl were about the same age and, according to Ramona, looked so alike that they got mistaken for sisters. Ramona's mom thought she could use her daughter's looks to lure out the Desert Killer.
作为解释，拉莫娜说她的妈妈是“德国人”。律师没让她进一步解释。但尽管这个计划很奇怪，它还是有一些逻辑的。拉莫娜和谢丽尔年纪相仿，据拉莫娜说，长得太像了，以至于被误认为是姐妹。拉莫娜的妈妈认为她可以利用女儿的长相引诱出“沙漠杀手”。
Ramona says that she and her mom did the Circle K routine over a few days with no luck. Then, one afternoon, she was sitting on a wall outside the store in her shorts when she saw a truck approach. Word around town was that the Desert Killer drove a beige or a brown truck.
拉莫娜说她和妈妈在那家Circle K做了几天的日常任务，没有运气。然后，一天下午，她穿着短裤坐在商店外的墙上时，看到一辆卡车靠近。城里的传言是“沙漠杀手”开着一辆米色或棕色的卡车。
One day, this brown truck came rolling in and went to the store and came out and looked over at me and was like, oh, shit. Threw a quarter at me-- go home. Huh? Go home. Your family's looking for you. They said I stole you, and the cops have been asking me questions. You need to take your ass home. And I'm like, who are you talking to? And I didn't know--
有一天，这辆棕色卡车开了进来，去了商店，出来后看着我，心想，噢，该死。扔了一枚硬币给我——回家。嗯？回家。你的家人在找你。他们说我偷了你，警察一直在问我问题。你需要带着你的屁股回家。我说，你在跟谁说话？我不知道——
This was how Ramona first met David Wood. At this point, the cops were starting to zero in on him for the disappearances, including Cheryl's, and he knew it. He mistakenly thought Ramona was Cheryl because, again, they looked alike. So that part of the plan actually worked. Ramona says he tossed a quarter at her as in, you're the girl the cops think I abducted. Please use this quarter to call home on the payphone. Tell everyone you're safe.
这就是拉莫娜第一次见到大卫·伍德的方式。此时，警察开始集中调查他的失踪案，包括谢丽尔的，而他知道这一点。他错误地认为拉莫娜就是谢丽尔，因为她们长得确实像。所以计划的那部分确实成功了。拉莫娜说他扔了一枚硬币给她，意思是，你是警察认为我绑架的那个女孩。请用这枚硬币在公用电话打回家。告诉大家你是安全的。
Ramona goes on to tell us about the surprising relationship that developed between her, her mom, and David Wood, something between a friendship and a covert op. David Wood himself remembers spending time with the two of them, but what he didn't know is that they were also spying on him. Ramona says her mom started inviting David Wood to their house.
拉莫娜继续告诉我们，她、她妈妈和大卫·伍德之间发展出的那种令人惊讶的关系，介于友谊和秘密行动之间。大卫·伍德本人记得和她们俩待在一起的时间，但他不知道的是她们也在监视他。拉莫娜说她妈妈开始邀请大卫·伍德到家里。
He'd come over, she'd give him coffee, they'd hang out, and they'd talk. My mom thought she was slick, and she was. My mom was like, I'm going to sit here and talk to him, you go search his truck.
他过来，她给他咖啡，他们待在一起，他们聊天。我妈妈以为她很滑头，确实也是。我妈妈说，我要坐在这里和他聊天，你去搜他的卡车。
She says she stole David Wood's keys and rifled through his truck, trying to find something incriminating. But she never did. She also saw him get nauseous around blood. She cut her hand in front of him once, which, while not exactly exonerating, didn't scream serial killer either. For Ramona and her mom, it all added up to one thing-- David Wood could not be the Desert Killer. Ramona says her mom was eager to help clear his name.
她说她偷了大卫·伍德的钥匙，在卡车里翻来覆去，试图找到定罪的东西。但她从来没找到。她还看到他在血面前会恶心。她有一次在他面前划伤了手，这虽然不能完全洗清罪名，但也并不尖叫着“连环杀手”。对拉莫娜和她妈妈来说，这一切加起来只有一个结论——大卫·伍德不可能是“沙漠杀手”。拉莫娜说她妈妈非常渴望帮忙洗清他的名字。
My mom immediately called the detectives. He's the wrong guy. You got the wrong guy because he didn't kidnap my daughter, and she looks just like Cheryl. And he threw a quarter at her and told her to go home. And my mom's German-- very feisty, very loud. She's like, da-da-da-da-da. So they're like, oh, we want to come and talk to you.
我妈立刻给侦探打了电话。他是错误的人。你们抓错人了，因为他没绑架我女儿，而她长得和谢丽尔一模一样。他扔了一枚硬币给她叫她回家。我妈是德国人——非常火爆，非常大声。她说，哒哒哒哒哒。所以他们说，噢，我们想过来和你谈谈。
The police came to the house and asked Ramona to come down to the station to give a statement to detectives. She was sketched out.
警察来到家里，要求拉莫娜去警察局给侦探一份声明。她感到很烦。
I said, no, I'm not going to give you a statement. And they said, well, we want to show you something. So they put me in the car and took me out to the desert. And they're like, there's bodies out here, and it'd be really easy for you to be out here. And they wanted me to write a statement. They told me, out there in the desert, we need you to go back and write a statement. We need you to tell us that David Wood tried to take you.
我说，不，我不会给你一份声明。他们说，嗯，我们想给你看点东西。于是他们把我塞进车里，带我去了沙漠。他们说，这里有尸体，你在这里很容易出事。他们要我写一份声明。他们告诉我，在那沙漠里，我们需要你回去写一份声明。我们需要你告诉我们大卫·伍德试图绑架你。
I said, but he didn't try to take me. He threw a quarter at me and told me to go home. He said, well, that's not what we need you to say. [CHUCKLES] I said, but that's not the truth. They said, you look just like all the other girls that are gone. This could be you. And I was like, are you threatening me? And they're like, well, no, we're just telling you that if you don't put him away, he might take you.
我说，但他没试图绑架我。他扔了一枚硬币给我，叫我回家。他说，嗯，那不是我们需要你说的。[笑声] 我说，但那不是事实。他们说，你长得和所有那些失踪的女孩一模一样。这可能是你。我心想，你们在威胁我吗？他们说，嗯，不，我们只是告诉你，如果你不把他关起来，他可能会绑架你。
Ramona says the detectives who drove her out to the desert were Johnny Guerrero and his partner, Alfonso Marquez. She eventually put all of this in a sworn statement to the court. Ramona is not the first person to accuse these guys of abusing their power. There's George Hall, the guy who called Greg with the whole story of the jailhouse informants and the red carpet treatment and later laid out his claims in a sworn declaration. According to trial transcripts, at least one other witness claimed the police tried to add falsehoods to her statement.
拉莫娜说带她去沙漠的侦探是约翰尼·格雷罗和他的搭档阿方索·马尔克斯。她最终把所有这些都写进了法庭宣誓声明中。拉莫娜不是第一个指责这些人滥用权力的人。还有乔治·霍尔，那个给格雷格打电话讲述狱中线人、红地毯招待等整个故事，后来在宣誓声明中列出他指控的人。根据审判记录，至少还有另一名证人声称警察试图在她的陈述中增加虚假内容。
In a different case from around this time, a suspect told a reporter that Detective Guerrero bullied him into a false confession. We asked Detective Guerrero about that interrogation, and he said he didn't remember it. He also denied ever taking Ramona out to the desert. Actually, what he said, was, quote, "She's full of shit." Moreover, he told us, in his 15 years in homicide, quote, "I was never accused of any wrongdoing or coercion by anyone I talked to or any case I worked," unquote.
在那个时期左右的另一个案件中，一名嫌疑人告诉记者，格雷罗侦探欺凌他以获得虚假供词。我们问了格雷罗侦探关于那次审讯的问题，他说他不记得了。他还否认曾经带拉莫娜去过沙漠。实际上，他说的是“她在胡说八道”。此外，他告诉我们，在他做凶杀案调查的15年里，“我从未被任何我交谈过的人或我处理的任何案件指控有任何不当行为或强迫行为。”
Detective Marquez, for his part, died a couple of years ago. But it is worth noting that he had a reputation for lying and using force. In a different case, he allegedly bullied a 16-year-old kid to make him confess to two murders. The kid was later exonerated after serving nearly 20 years in prison.
马尔克斯侦探几年前去世了。但值得注意的是，他有撒谎和使用暴力的名声。在另一个案件中，他据称欺凌了一个16岁的孩子，迫使他承认犯下两起谋杀案。那个孩子在服刑近20年后被平反。
Watching the lawyers interview Ramona, watching them jot down notes at every twist and turn, I was struck by how absurd it was that this was where we found ourselves, 50 days out from the execution, all of us huddled around a table in this Whataburger, the lawyers trying to piece together something useful from this zany story. Ramona is entertaining, but since I'm not steeped in the case, it also seems like she mixes theories and stories and gossip and evidence so effortlessly and at such a rapid clip, that it's a little hard to keep up, much less to accept it all at face value.
看着律师采访拉莫娜，看着他们在每一个转折处记下笔记，我感到非常荒谬，这就是我们发现自己所在的地方，距离处决还有50天，我们所有人都挤在Whataburger的一张桌子旁，律师们试图从这个滑稽的故事中拼凑出有用的东西。拉莫娜很有娱乐性，但由于我不了解此案，她似乎毫不费力地以如此快的速度混合理论、故事、八卦和证据，以至于很难跟上，更不用说全盘接受了。
Yeah, right, right.
是的，对，对。
I look over at Greg and Naomi to see how they're reacting, to get some clue about how seriously I should take all of this, but they're more or less statues. Very stoic, these two lawyers in a Whataburger. All of which to say, I'm not sure how to assess some of the other claims Ramona makes. The most explosive ones concern a very important person in the case against David Wood, Judith Kelling.
我看向格雷格和娜奥米看他们的反应，以得到关于我应该多认真对待这一切的线索，但他们或多或少是雕像。在Whataburger的这两位律师非常冷漠。所有这些都是说，我不确定如何评估拉莫娜提出的其他一些主张。最劲爆的主张涉及大卫·伍德案中的一个非常重要的人，朱迪思·凯林。
And when I heard her name, I'm like, this is that prostitute that's saying David raped her.
当我听到她的名字时，我心想，这就是那个说大卫强奸了她的妓女。
Yes.
是的。
Judith Kelling was the woman who claimed David Wood raped her out in the desert. Ramona says she was out one day, looking for her sister-in-law, who was still missing, when she spotted Kelling and sidled up to her.
朱迪思·凯林就是那个声称大卫·伍德在沙漠里强奸她的女人。拉莫娜说有一天她出去寻找仍然失踪的嫂子时，发现了凯林并悄悄接近了她。
So I'm playing it cool with her, and I'm like, oh, yeah, I'm looking for my sister, and da-da-da-da. And she's like, oh, the David Wood thing. She's like, yeah, that's all bullshit. I was like, what do you mean? And she's like, he didn't do anything to me.
所以我对她表现得冷静，我说，噢，是的，我在找我姐姐，哒哒哒。她说，噢，大卫·伍德那个案子。她说，是的，那全是胡扯。我说，什么意思？她说，他没对我做任何事。
Really?
真的？
Really.
真的。
She told you this after David was arrested in October of 1987.
她在大卫1987年10月被捕后告诉你的。
Here after he was arrested, after he was already charged with her rape, what he was charged with before he was--
在这里他被捕后，在他被控强奸她之后，在他——之前——
You can tell in Greg's voice how much he would love to poke holes in Judith Kelling's credibility. It's something he's been trying to do for years. For example, he found one source who gave a sworn statement to the court that Judith Kelling had been a police informant, and specifically that she'd been Detective Johnny Guerrero's informant when she reported her rape.
你可以从格雷格的声音中听出他有多想戳穿朱迪思·凯林的可信度。这是他多年来一直试图做的事情。例如，他找到了一个向法庭提供宣誓声明的来源，称朱迪思·凯林曾是警方线人，特别是在她举报强奸时，她是约翰尼·格雷罗侦探的线人。
Judith also spent long stretches in jail around this time on drug charges. On top of that, Greg has noticed that her story of what exactly happened in the desert kept changing, getting more and more aligned with other things the police believed about David Wood and the murders. Greg uses these points to make an argument in court filings. Desperate to solve the murders, Detective Guerrero squeezed an equally desperate Judith Kelling to point the finger at David Wood.
朱迪思当时也因为毒品指控在监狱里呆了很长时间。最重要的是，格雷格注意到她在沙漠中究竟发生了什么的故事一直在变，变得越来越符合警察关于大卫·伍德和谋杀案的其他看法。格雷格在法庭文件中利用这些观点进行辩论。急于解决谋杀案，格雷罗侦探挤压同样绝望的朱迪思·凯林，让她指向大卫·伍德。
We asked Detective Guerrero about all of this, and he denies that Kelling was ever his informant. Judith Kelling died a decade ago, so Greg can't ask her about it. But here, in this Whataburger, Ramona claims Kelling revealed much more to her about what really went down.
我们问了格雷罗侦探所有这些问题，他否认凯林曾经是他的线人。朱迪思·凯林十年前去世了，所以格雷格无法问她。但在这里，在这个Whataburger，拉莫娜声称凯林向她透露了更多关于真正发生了什么的事情。
This is what she's telling me. They made a deal with me to get me out of jail, and all I got to do is testify against this guy. I was like, well, were you even raped? She's like, yeah, but not by him. I'm like, who? She said, Mike Plyler. I'm like, who's this guy?
这就是她告诉我的。他们和我做了交易把我弄出监狱，我所要做的就是在这个人身上作证。我说，那你真的被强奸了吗？她说，是的，但不是他。我说，谁？她说，迈克·普莱勒。我说，这个家伙是谁？
Mike Plyler? What? The same guy Greg asked about at the courthouse a few hours ago? The one I thought was a long shot? I look over at Greg, and I can see he's just as surprised. He's barely able to contain himself, nodding so hard it's like he's swaying.
迈克·普莱勒？什么？格雷格几个小时前在法院询问的同一个人？我以为那是极不可能的一条线索？我看向格雷格，我能看出他和我一样惊讶，他几乎无法控制自己，点着头，点得非常用力，就像在摇晃一样。
Ramona says that after she got Mike Plyler's name from Judith, she and her mom looked for the guy and, well, basically stalked him. They staked out his apartment, watched him come and go. They were blown away by the similarities between this man and David Wood-- similar builds, similar tattoos. On top of the similar trucks, they also both drove red motorcycles. I can practically see the gears turning in Greg's mind. And as the Whataburger fills with the sound of someone making the world's loudest milkshake, he tosses out one more question.
拉莫娜说在从朱迪思那里得到迈克·普莱勒的名字后，她和妈妈找了那个家伙，好吧，基本上跟踪了他。她们盯着他的公寓，看着他来来去去。这个人和大卫·伍德之间的相似之处让她们惊呆了——相似的身材、相似的纹身。除了相似的卡车，他们都开红色的摩托车。我几乎可以看到格雷格脑子里的齿轮在转动。当Whataburger里充满了某人制作世界最大奶昔的声音时，他抛出了最后一个问题。
Do you have any information about this nickname Skeeter that supposedly is--
关于这个叫斯基特的绰号，你有什么信息吗，据说是——
That's Skeeter. Mike Plyler's Skeeter.
那就是斯基特。迈克·普莱勒就是斯基特。
Well, when you say that, how do you know that he's Skeeter?
嗯，当你这么说时，你怎么知道他是斯基特？
Because that's what Judith called him.
因为朱迪思就是那么叫他的。
Is that right?
是吗？
That's what she called him. She called him Skeeter. So that's Skeeter.
她就是那么叫他的。她叫他斯基特。所以那就是斯基特。
Ramona says that she went to the cops back in 1987 and told them everything she learned, about David Wood, about Judith Kelling, and about Michael Plyler. And, she says, the cops did nothing. They could have, for example, looked more into Plyler, gotten some DNA samples, polygraphed him. Instead, Ramona says, they simply told her to stay away.
拉莫娜说她在1987年去了警察局，告诉了他们关于大卫·伍德、朱迪思·凯林和迈克·普莱勒的所有事情。她说，警察什么都没做。例如，他们本可以更多地调查普莱勒，获取一些DNA样本，给他做测谎。拉莫娜说，相反，他们只是告诉她远离。
Ramona's whole story is wild, obviously. And as we wrap up at the Whataburger, it's not clear to me how Greg is going to use it all, whether he's going to try to corroborate any of these details. And I'm not sure that's really possible. I can imagine what a prosecutor might say. For example, the Judith Kelling story, that it wasn't David Wood who raped her, well, the state could point to trial testimony from Kelling's sister, who said Judith identified David Wood as the rapist right after it happened. Greg could go after the sister's credibility, but the question remains, why would Judith Kelling make a grand revelation to Ramona, a teenager she just met?
拉莫娜的整个故事显然是疯狂的。当我们结束Whataburger的访谈时，我不清楚格雷格打算如何利用这一切，他是否打算试图证实这些细节。我不确定这真的可能。我可以想象检察官会怎么说。例如，朱迪思·凯林的故事，说强奸她的不是大卫·伍德，好吧，州政府可以指出凯林姐妹在审判中的证词，她说朱迪思在事情发生后立刻指认大卫·伍德为强奸犯。格雷格可以攻击那个姐妹的可信度，但问题仍然存在，为什么朱迪思·凯林要向她刚认识的一个青少年拉莫娜透露一个惊人的秘密？
There's also a question about Ramona's motivations. I found an old news story that says she was banned from the El Paso County Jail. She had allegedly graffitied "I love David Wood" on the wall of a visiting booth. Ramona denies it and says people were just out to tarnish her reputation because she was questioning the police department's version of events. Still, not a great thing to have out there on the internet.
关于拉莫娜的动机也有问题。我找到一篇旧新闻报道，说她被禁止进入埃尔帕索县监狱。据称她在探视区的墙上涂鸦了“我爱大卫·伍德”。拉莫娜否认了这一点，说人们只是想抹黑她的名声，因为她质疑警察局对事件的描述。不过，在互联网上出现这些事总归不太好。
But what's most useful to Greg, I think, are all those moments when the cops appeared to have tunnel vision. For example, when Ramona says they tried to get her to falsely accuse David Wood or when she says they ignored the Plyler story, especially if the state didn't tell Wood's lawyers about this stuff before his trial. I wouldn't call these bombshells, but I would call them good evidence. And you could argue that Greg only found it all because the execution date forced him to knock on every door one more time.
但我认为对格雷格最有用的，是警察似乎有隧道视野的所有那些时刻。例如，当拉莫娜说他们试图让她虚假指控大卫·伍德时，或者当她说他们忽视了普莱勒的故事时，如果州政府在审判前没有把这些东西告诉伍德的律师，那就更是如此了。我不会把这些称为重磅炸弹，但我会把它们称为好的证据。而且你可以说，格雷格找到这一切只是因为执行日期迫使他再次敲开了每一扇门。
I ended up calling Mike Plyler a few weeks later. He confirmed that he did live in El Paso during the time in question. His tone got a little sharp when I asked if he went by the nickname Skeeter. He interrupted me and said, quote, "That's false." When asked about raping anyone or being the Desert Killer, he said, quote, "I haven't done nothing. I don't have nothing to hide." After we hung up, I sent him Ramona's claims. He ghosted me.
几周后我给迈克·普莱勒打了电话。他证实他在相关时期确实住在埃尔帕索。当我问他是否用过“斯基特”这个绰号时，他的语气有点尖锐。他打断我说：“那是假的。”当被问及是否强奸过任何人或是否是“沙漠杀手”时，他说：“我没做什么。我没什么可隐瞒的。”在我们挂断电话后，我给他发了拉莫娜的主张。他不理我了。
I do feel for him. This whole episode made me see just how easy it is for anyone to be accused of pretty egregious stuff in a legal filing, in this case, rape and being a suspect in a serial murder case, all because some stranger mentions your name in a Whataburger. We felt we had to use Plyler's name, given how much it showed up in the lawyer's legal filing, but we also felt like this man deserves every possible opportunity to respond. So after I sent a ton of follow-ups that went unanswered, Alvin and I decided we just had to try in person.
我确实同情他。整个节目让我看到，仅仅因为某个陌生人在Whataburger提到你的名字，任何人就很容易在法律文件中被指控犯有相当严重的罪行，在这种情况下是强奸和作为连环谋杀案的嫌疑人。考虑到他的名字在律师的法律文件中出现得如此频繁，我们觉得必须使用普莱勒的名字，但也觉得这个人应该得到每一个可能的回应机会。所以在发了一堆无人回复的跟进信息后，阿尔文和我觉得我们必须当面尝试。
Plyler lives in a mid-sized city in the south. When we got to his house, there were a couple of warning signs about a pitbull, and then we heard barking. I did see a dog through the window-- pretty cute, actually. Plyler opened up just to tell us, quote, "I'm not interested." I asked if I could give him a folder with Ramona's claims. He suggested I throw it in the garbage. I leaned over to put it on the doormat, and by the time I stood back up, the door was closed. The whole thing lasted maybe 10 seconds. I haven't been able to reach him since.
普莱勒住在南部的一个中型城市。当我们到达他家时，有几个关于斗牛犬的警告标志，然后我们听到了狗叫声。我确实透过窗户看到了一只狗——实际上相当可爱。普莱勒打开门只是为了告诉我们：“我不感兴趣。”我问是否可以给他一个文件夹，里面装着拉莫娜的主张。他建议我把它扔进垃圾桶。我弯下腰把它放在门垫上，当我站起来时，门已经关上了。整个过程持续了大约10秒。从那以后我再也联系不上他了。
Maurice Chammah. That is from his brand-new podcast, The Last 12 Weeks, which is made by Serial with The New York Times and the Marshall Project. You can hear the rest, the promising leads, the disappointing leads, the far-fetched leads, everything they try in this true-life crime story.
马歇尔项目莫里斯·查马。那是来自他全新的播客《最后12周》，该播客由《Serial》与《纽约时报》和马歇尔项目共同制作。你可以收听余下的内容，那些有希望的线索、令人失望的线索、牵强的线索，以及他们在这一真实犯罪故事中尝试的一切。
When you do-- I just want to give you a heads up-- you've now heard about 10 minutes of episode one and 15 minutes of episode two, so most of those two episodes, you're going to want to go back and hear the stuff we haven't included today. You can hear that, The Last 12 Weeks, wherever you get your podcasts.
当你收听时——我只是想提醒你——你现在已经听了第一集大约10分钟和第二集15分钟，所以大部分那两集内容你还需要回去收听我们今天没有包含的部分。你可以在任何你获取播客的地方收听《最后12周》。
Coming up, people tossing out a real-life message in a bottle every single Sunday, hoping someone will respond. That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，人们每一个星期天都在漂流瓶中发出一封真实生活的求救信，希望能有人回应。这一内容将在芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续中揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, There's Something About Hail Mary. As I said earlier, we're spending this entire hour in the last two minutes of the fourth quarter with people who are behind and desperate, trying any damn thing they can think of. We've arrived at Act Two of our program, Act Two, Bottle Episode.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“关于万福玛丽的一些事”。正如我之前所说，我们要把整个小时都花在第四节的最后两分钟里，与那些落后、绝望，尝试任何能想到的该死办法的人们在一起。我们进入节目的第二幕，瓶中插曲。
What is the plural of Hail Mary? Is it Hail Marys? It seems like it should be the "hail" part that gets to be the part that's plural because that's the action, right? That's the thing that's happening. But just Hails Mary just sounds weird. I ask this because Miki Meek has this story where you need the plural.
万福玛丽（Hail Mary）的复数是什么？是Hail Marys吗？似乎应该是“Hail”这个词变成复数，因为那是动作，对吧？那是正在发生的事情。但Hails Mary听起来很奇怪。我问这个是因为米基·米克（Miki Meek）有这个故事，你需要用到复数。
Aisha Wallace Palomares came across this thing sort of by accident. She's an immigration reporter for a website called LA Taco. And she heard about a lot of people gathering every week outside a detention center called Otay Mesa in San Diego. It's in a pretty desolate spot, surrounded by industrial parks and mountains with off-roading trails.
阿伊莎·华莱士·帕洛马雷斯（Aisha Wallace Palomares）偶然发现了这件事。她是名为“LA Taco”网站的移民记者。她听说每周都有很多人聚集在圣地亚哥一个叫奥泰梅萨（Otay Mesa）的拘留中心外。那是一个相当荒凉的地方，被工业园区和带有越野小径的山脉所包围。
I think, actually, when I first walked up, I think Kiss was playing. [CHUCKLES] A Kiss song was playing. And I just remember very cozy, very friendly, very positive. Even though this was across-- you're looking at this detention center that has beige walls and two layers of fence with barbed wire. And it's just a very stark contrast.
我想实际上，我第一次走过去时，我想正在放KISS乐队的歌。[笑声] 在放一首KISS的歌。我只记得非常舒适、非常友好、非常积极。尽管这是在对面——你正在看着这个有着米色墙壁和两层带刺铁丝网围栏的拘留中心。这是一种非常鲜明的对比。
It was a whole group of people, about 150 who brought their dogs and kids. They wanted the people inside to know they were there, which is kind of a puzzle because of the fences, hence the music, which they played pretty loud. They also flew kites, and the kids blew bubbles, hoping to get some of them over the detention center's walls. Aisha watched a pastor walk up to a microphone and speaker that was set up.
那是一大群人，大约150人，带着他们的狗和孩子。他们想让里面的人知道他们在那里，这有点像个谜，因为有围栏，所以他们把音乐放得很大声。他们还放了风筝，孩子们吹泡泡，希望能让其中一些飘过拘留中心的墙壁。阿伊莎看着一位牧师走近设置好的麦克风和扬声器。
And he turned around and faced the detention center, and he said, all right, everyone, I want you guys to yell, you are not alone!
他转过身面对拘留中心，说：“好的，大家，我要你们大声喊，你们不孤单！”
You are not alone. Let's say it to the hostages behind us.
你们不孤单。让我们对我们身后的人质说。
You are not alone!
你们不孤单！
So two more times.
再来两次。
You are not alone!
你们不孤单！
There are more than 1,300 detainees inside Otay Mesa. And a lot of them don't have a good, reliable way to communicate with the outside world. In theory, they should be able to make phone calls. There are these tablets they can use to text or do video chats.
奥泰梅萨里有超过1300名被拘留者。他们很多人没有与外部世界沟通的好、可靠的方式。理论上，他们应该能打电话。他们有这些可以用作发短信或视频聊天的平板电脑。
But the reality is that they have to pay to do any of that. And a lot of people land in detention without any money. And sometimes their families have no idea where they've been taken. They can try to look it up online in ICE's Detainee Locator, but that's not always accurate or up-to-date. And if you're wondering, don't people have a right to a free phone call? The answer is no.
但现实是，他们得付钱才能做任何这些事。很多人在没有任何钱的情况下被拘留。有时他们的家人根本不知道他们被带到了哪里。他们可以尝试在移民局的被拘留者定位系统中在线查找，但这并不总是准确或最新的。如果你在想，人们难道没有免费打电话的权利吗？答案是没有。
And then I just start to notice that they're calling over the fence.
然后我开始注意到他们正在隔着围栏呼叫。
[SHOUTING]
[呼喊声]
The organizers ask for A-numbers.
组织者要求提供A号码。
Can you just explain what's an A-number?
你能解释一下什么是A号码吗？
Yeah, it's called an alien number. It's basically a number that is designated to someone who is a non-citizen. And A-numbers are really important for family members to locate their loved ones when they've been detained.
是的，它被称为外籍人士号码。它基本上是指定给非公民身份的人的号码。对于家人在他们被拘留时定位亲人来说，A号码非常重要。
If they can get someone's A-number, organizers can put money directly on their books. The organizers then started shushing people. Everyone went silent, which Aisha thought was kind of strange until--
如果他们能得到某人的A号码，组织者可以直接把钱打到他们的账上。组织者开始让人们安静下来。所有人都沉默了，阿伊莎觉得这有点奇怪，直到——
I heard people yell from inside the detention center.
我听到人们从拘留中心里面大喊大叫。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语讲话]
Wow.
哇。
Someone was saying, Russia. So at first, the organizers thought that they were requesting someone who speaks Russian. But then they were realizing that the person inside was telling them that the A-number they were sharing was Russian.
有人在喊，俄罗斯。起初，组织者以为他们是在要求找一个会说俄语的人。但随后他们意识到里面的人是在告诉他们，他们分享的A号码是俄罗斯人的。
OK, Russia. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
好的，俄罗斯。[说西班牙语]
They had translators on hand for at least 13 languages, including Arabic, Russian, Swahili, and Tagalog. A couple people stood by with notebooks and wrote A-numbers into them. They then immediately tried sending money through these apps, up to $20 for phone calls and text messages and another $45 for commissary. That was the goal-- get as many A-numbers as possible.
他们手头有至少13种语言的翻译，包括阿拉伯语、俄语、斯瓦希里语和他加禄语。几个人拿着笔记本站在旁边，把A号码写进去。然后他们立即尝试通过这些应用程序汇款，最高20美元用于打电话和发短信，另外45美元用于购买杂货。这就是目标——尽可能多地获取A号码。
[SHOUTING]
[呼喊声]
It was hard to hear, even when everyone was quiet.
即使在每个人都安静时也很难听清。
This is not like the easiest way to communicate, right?
这不是最简单的交流方式，对吧？
Like, have you heard of this kind of thing happening at other detention centers before?
比如，你以前听说过这种事情发生在其他拘留中心吗？
No, I have not. This is the first time that I had heard anything like this before.
没有，我没有。这是我第一次听说这样的事。
Detainees were yelling from different outdoor yards, little patches of concrete with a single basketball hoop. So at some point, someone started bringing a listening device with a parabolic dish. And it's not the only way they communicated.
被拘留者从不同的室外操场大喊大叫，那些是一小块水泥地，带一个篮球架。所以有人开始带着带抛物面天线的监听设备。而且这并不是他们交流的唯一方式。
I guess, there's a drain in one of the yards, or I'm not sure if it's in every yard. And so some of the detainees started kneeling and yelling through the hole.
我想，其中一个操场有个排水管，或者我不确定每个操场是不是都有。所以一些被拘留者开始跪着对着洞口喊叫。
The organizers, who call themselves the Otay Mesa Detention Collective, told Aisha that the first time they realized they could communicate through bullhorns and shouting was shortly after they started gathering outside the detention center last fall. They were giving out tamales and bags of fruit to families coming for visiting hours, when they heard a woman yelling from inside the detention center. She was yelling on behalf of another woman who was inside and far from her family. Here's a recording of that.
自称为奥泰梅萨拘留集体的组织者告诉阿伊莎，他们第一次意识到可以通过扩音器和喊叫进行交流，是在去年秋天开始聚集在拘留中心外后不久。他们给来探视时间的家庭分发墨西哥粽和水果袋时，听到一个女人从拘留中心里面大喊。她在为一个在里面、离家人很远的另一个女人呼喊。这里有一段录音。
She's from Oxnard, 19 years old, and she's here!
她来自奥克斯纳德，19岁，她就在这儿！
She's only 19 years old? What's her name? She's from Oxnard, California. She wants her family to know she's here. What's her name?
她只有19岁？她叫什么名字？她来自加利福尼亚州的奥克斯纳德。她想让她家人知道她在这儿。她叫什么名字？
Her name was Yulissa, and her family did not know where she was. And so they were asking if the organizers could connect with the family or just get some help so that her family could know that she was in Otay Mesa.
她的名字叫尤丽莎，她的家人不知道她在哪儿。所以他们问组织者能否联系家人，或者只是提供帮助，以便她的家人知道她在奥泰梅萨。
I just want to get deported because I want to get out of here! [CRYING]
我只是想被驱逐出境，因为我想离开这儿！[哭泣]
One of the organizers posted video of that exchange on Instagram, and it went viral. Someone responded in a comment, "She's my in-law," and then set up a GoFundMe that said Yulissa's family had been looking for her for a week. Until then, all they knew was that she never showed up to pick up her one-year-old daughter from daycare.
其中一名组织者在Instagram上发布了那段交流的视频，它火了。有人在评论中回应：“她是我的姻亲，”然后建立了一个GoFundMe页面，说尤丽莎的家人已经找了她一个星期。在此之前，他们所知道的只是她没有去日托中心接她一岁的女儿。
When Aisha first saw that video, she thought it was something that had happened once. She didn't realize it was happening all the time until she was there. In the middle of all these A-numbers being shouted out, another thing happened.
当阿伊莎第一次看到那段视频时，她以为那是发生过一次的事情。直到她身临其境，才意识到这一直在发生。在所有被喊出的A号码中，另一件事发生了。
I was just observing, and I saw people scramble, the organizer scramble and say, there's a bottle, there's a bottle! And then I see a CoreCivic truck start to drive down.
我只是在观察，看到人们争先恐后，组织者争先恐后地说，有个瓶子，有个瓶子！然后我看到一辆CoreCivic卡车开始开过去。
CoreCivic is the private company that runs this detention center.
CoreCivic是经营这个拘留中心的私营公司。
It was a game of who was going to get there first, the CoreCivic security truck or the vigil attendee. And one of the vigil attendees ended up grabbing the bottle and bringing it back. And then it was like a bottle. Like, what?
这是一场谁先到达那里的游戏，是CoreCivic保安卡车还是守夜参加者。其中一名守夜参加者最终抓住了瓶子并把它带了回来。那就像一个瓶子。比如，什么？
What kind of bottle was it?
那是什么样的瓶子？
It was a lotion bottle. You know, like, a travel-sized lotion bottle? And I was just, in that moment, like, someone threw a bottle from inside the detention facility. It's a pretty wide distance to throw something over. They have to throw it from inside of this pod, yard, over the cement wall, and then it has to go across-- I mean, I'm not sure how tall this fence is, maybe 14 to 20 feet tall, and it has barbed wire on it. And that's one fence. Then there's a little gap, and there's another fence. And it's also tall and barbed wire.
那是一个乳液瓶。你知道，那种旅行装的乳液瓶吗？就在那一刻，我心想，有人从拘留设施里面扔了一个瓶子。扔过一个东西是很远的距离。他们得从这个吊舱、操场里面扔出来，越过水泥墙，然后它得越过——我的意思是，我不确定这个围栏有多高，也许14到20英尺高，上面有带刺的铁丝网。那是一个围栏。然后有一个小缺口，有另一个围栏。它也很高，也有带刺铁丝网。
That is really wild.
这真的很疯狂。
Yeah, and I was just-- I had chills. I was like, that's insane.
是的，我当时——我起了鸡皮疙瘩。我心想，这太疯狂了。
I measured it on Google Maps. The shortest distance they would have had to throw the lotion bottle is about 90 feet.
我在谷歌地图上测量了。他们必须扔掉那个乳液瓶的最短距离大约是90英尺。
I noticed that everyone kind of got excited. And then I think-- I don't know if it was Bleu or Holly walks over to me and says, there was a note attached to the bottle. And I was like, what?
我注意到每个人都感到有点兴奋。然后我想——我不确定是Bleu还是Holly走过来对我说，瓶子上附着一张纸条。我当时想，什么？
Is it attached to it, or is it inside of it?
它是附在上面的，还是在里面的？
It's attached to it. I think they used the sticker on the bottle to use that adhesive to somehow attach the note to that. And then that's what it was wrapped on.
它是附在上面的。我想他们用了瓶子上的贴纸来利用粘合剂以某种方式把纸条附在那个上面。然后那就是它被包裹的东西。
So Bleu brings it over to you, and--
所以Bleu把它带过来给你，然后——
She says, do you want to hold it? My stomach kind of dropped, and I said, yes. And I'm just holding this note in my hands, and I'm reading it.
她说，你想拿着吗？我的胃有点下沉，我说，是的。我就拿着这张纸条，我正在读它。
I was wondering, can you read that message for me?
我在想，你能为我读一下那条信息吗？
Yeah, I can. "Good afternoon. My wife and I have been at OMDC since April 15, 2025. It's cold here all the time, and the food is poor. For 290 days, we haven't eaten a single piece of fruit, banana, apple, orange, or anything fresh. We are all in one big room with no doors or windows. We can't see any grass or trees. We are all constantly sick. There is no internet. My lawyer was not given my phone calls. Many people here have been sitting for 12, 14, 16, 18 months without a final court decision."
是的，我可以。“下午好。我和我妻子自2025年4月15日起就在OMDC了。这里一直很冷，食物很差。290天来，我们没吃过一块水果、香蕉、苹果、橙子或任何新鲜东西。我们都挤在一个没有门窗的大房间里。我们看不到任何草地或树木。我们都一直生病。没有互联网。我的律师没有收到我的电话。这里很多人在没有最终法庭裁决的情况下已经坐了12、14、16、18个月了。”
Aisha asked the main organizer, a preschool teacher with bright blue hair named Jeane Wong, is this the first time someone had thrown a note over to them?
阿伊莎问主要组织者，一位留着亮蓝色头发的学前班老师珍·黄，这是有人第一次扔纸条给他们吗？
And then Jeane tells me that this is not the first note, that there are several notes that they've received, but this is the longest note that they've had. Most of them have had A-numbers, but she says that this person from inside was so desperate to have their story told that they had actually thrown another bottle with the same exact note earlier that day.
然后珍告诉我，这不是第一张纸条，他们收到过好几张，但这是他们收到的最长的纸条。大多数都有A号码，但她说这个里面的人如此绝望想要讲出他们的故事，以至于他们当天早些时候扔了另一个带有完全相同纸条的瓶子。
What kind of other objects have come over?
还有什么其他东西被扔过来了？
Lotion bottles, deodorant bottles, and I think even a AA battery.
乳液瓶、除臭剂瓶，我想甚至还有一节AA电池。
Most of what they got that day were A-numbers. Aisha says about 50, mostly from people shouting and throwing bottles over with multiple numbers scrawled on them. I reached out to CoreCivic about the conditions described in the letter that Aisha read. They denied all the allegations, called them flatly false and inconsistent with their standards.
那天他们收到的大多是A号码。阿伊莎说大约50个，大多来自人们大喊大叫，并扔过来带有乱涂乱画的多个号码的瓶子。我联系了CoreCivic关于阿伊莎读到的信件中描述的情况。他们否认了所有指控，称它们完全是虚假的，与他们的标准不符。
There have been reports for decades about inhumane living conditions and poor medical care at Otay Mesa and other ICE detention facilities. But these problems have gotten a lot worse since President Trump returned to office, because the number of people in detention has increased so dramatically, things like overcrowding, not getting enough food, or getting food that's spoiled, also, physical and verbal abuse from guards. One of the biggest issues right now-- detainees needing medical treatment and not getting it.
几十年来，一直有关于奥泰梅萨和其他移民局拘留中心存在不人道生活条件和医疗保健差的报道。但自从特朗普总统重返办公室以来，这些问题变得更糟了，因为拘留人数增加得如此巨大，像过度拥挤、食物不够，或得到变质的食物，还有来自警卫的身体和言语虐待。现在最大的问题之一——被拘留者需要医疗护理却得不到。
Over the past year, the death rate in ICE custody has more than doubled compared to recent years, more than 50 people since President Trump came back to office. One of them was a Haitian man named Emmanuel Damas. He went into septic shock from a toothache.
在过去的一年里，与近年来相比，移民局拘留所的死亡率翻了一倍多，特朗普总统回来后已经有超过50人死亡。其中一人是名叫伊曼纽尔·达马斯的海地男子。他因牙疼引发感染性休克而死亡。
It's worth noting that most people in ICE detention facilities do not have a criminal record. Crossing the border illegally or overstaying a visa is not a criminal offense. It's a civil violation. And immigration detention is not supposed to be punitive like a prison. Many immigration lawyers believe the administration is trying to wear people down by holding them for long periods in these harsh conditions, so they'll give up on their cases and agree to deportation.
值得注意的是，移民局拘留中心的大多数人都没有犯罪记录。非法越境或签证逾期不是刑事犯罪。这是一种民事违规。移民拘留不应该像监狱那样具有惩罚性。许多移民律师认为，政府试图通过将人们长期关押在这些恶劣环境中来消磨他们的意志，这样他们就会放弃案件并同意被驱逐出境。
While Aisha was there, some of the detainees who'd gotten money put into their accounts sent text messages to the organizers. They requested music they wanted organizers to blast. Others wanted their texts read out loud.
当阿伊莎在那里时，一些钱被存入账户的被拘留者给组织者发送了短信。他们要求组织者播放他们想要的音乐。其他人想要他们的短信被大声朗读出来。
We just got a text from someone inside, and so she's going to read it for everybody here, OK?
我们刚从里面收到一条短信，所以她要读给这里的每个人听，好吗？
I put it into Google Translate, and it said, are you guys outside? We can hear you. We can hear you. We can hear you. We love you. Thank you.
我把它放进谷歌翻译，上面说，你们在外面吗？我们能听到你们。我们能听到你们。我们能听到你们。我们爱你们。谢谢。
[CHEERING, APPLAUSE]
[欢呼，掌声]
At the end of the day, the organizers asked Aisha, please don't publish anything about how we're communicating with detainees. They worried it would all get shut down. But then they texted the people inside, including the person who threw over the lotion bottle, and asked what they thought. The answer? Publish it. The detainees wanted the story out. They wanted people to know what was happening.
在一天结束时，组织者问阿伊莎，请不要发表任何关于我们如何与被拘留者沟通的内容。他们担心这一切会被关闭。但随后他们给里面的人发了短信，包括扔出乳液瓶的人，问他们怎么想。答案是什么？发表。被拘留者想要这个故事流传出去。他们想要人们知道发生了什么。
Aisha's story ran, and then, as predicted, there was retaliation, according to detainees. They said that CoreCivic turned down temperatures, took away showers, limited tablet access and commissary time, and shut down the yard on Sunday afternoons when the organizers are outside, which means no more messages on bottles thrown over fences. But it doesn't matter. The organizers now have enough A-numbers that they're communicating with hundreds of detainees by text.
阿伊莎的故事发表了，然后正如预期的那样，据被拘留者称，发生了报复。他们说CoreCivic降低了设施内的温度，剥夺了洗澡机会，限制了平板电脑使用和购买杂货的时间，并关闭了周日下午组织者在外面时的操场，这意味着不再有扔过围栏的纸条瓶子了。但这没关系。组织者现在有足够的A号码，他们正在通过短信与数百名被拘留者沟通。
Miki Meek is a producer on our show. When we reached out to CoreCivic, they denied that temperatures inside the facility were kept deliberately uncomfortable, and they said they have a zero-tolerance policy for retaliation against detainees. ICE did not respond to our request for comment. You can find more of Aisha Wallace Palomares's reporting at the website, LA Taco.
米基·米克是我们节目的制作人。当我们联系CoreCivic时，他们否认设施内部的温度是被人为调得让人感到不适，并表示他们对被拘留者的报复行为实行“零容忍”政策。移民局没有回应我们的置评请求。你可以在网站LA Taco上找到阿伊莎·华莱士·帕洛马雷斯的更多报道。
["COMING IN ON A WING AND A PRAYER" BY RY COODER]
Our program was produced today by Aviva DeKornfeld. The people who put together today's show include Adriene Lilly, Molly Marcello, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Ruthie Petitto, Robin Reid, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们今天的节目由阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德制作。今天节目制作人员包括阿德里恩·莉莉、莫莉·马塞洛、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、鲁西·佩蒂托、罗宾·里德、纳迪亚·雷曼、安东尼·罗曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、弗朗西丝·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉和朱莉·惠特克。我们的主编是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的资深编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。
Serial's new series that we excerpted, The Last 12 Weeks, was produced by Alvin Melathe. The series was edited by Jen Guerra, along with Anita Badejo. Additional editing by Julie Snyder, Sarah Koenig, and Akiba Solomon. Research and fact-checking by Ben Phelan. Scoring by Adam Dorn, a.k.a. Mocean Worker, Matthias Bossi, and Jon Evans of Stellwagen Symphonette. Additional music by Dan Powell and Marion Lozano. Phoebe Wang and Catherine Anderson mixed the show.
我们摘录的《Serial》新系列《最后12周》由阿尔文·梅拉特制作。该系列由简·格拉和安妮塔·巴德乔编辑。额外编辑由朱莉·斯奈德、莎拉·凯尼格和阿基巴·所罗门完成。由本·费伦进行研究和事实核查。配乐由亚当·多恩，又名Mocean Worker，马蒂亚斯·博西和斯特尔瓦根交响乐团的乔恩·埃文斯完成。额外音乐由丹·鲍威尔和马里昂·洛扎诺提供。菲比·王和凯瑟琳·安德森混合了节目。
Special thanks today to Dr. David Scales, Mark Soloski, Dr. Charlotte Mao, Dr. Eboni Cornish, The San Diego Bike Brigade, The American Bar Association's Immigration Justice Project, The San Diego County Immigrant Legal Defense Program, Mack Miller, Sean Cole, Susan Wessling, Al-Amyn Sumar, Jackson Busch, Ruth Baldwin, Tom Meagher, Rita Radostitz, and Sean Devaney.
今天特别感谢大卫·斯凯尔斯博士、马克·索洛斯基、夏洛特·毛博士、埃博尼·康沃尔博士、圣地亚哥自行车大队、美国律师协会移民司法项目、圣地亚哥县移民法律辩护项目、麦克·米勒、肖恩·科尔、苏珊·韦斯林、阿尔-阿明·苏马尔、杰克逊·布希、露丝·鲍德温、汤姆·米格尔、丽塔·拉多斯蒂茨和肖恩·德瓦尼。
Thanks today to This American Life Partners Suzanne Hershey, Leslie Ferrin, Gabrielle Rhode, and Peter James. I hope that you will consider joining them as a Life Partner. And why? It allows us to keep making the program. A significant part of our budget now comes from our Life Partners. We're hoping that number is going to grow. To thank you, we'll give you dozens of bonus episodes that we've made that have come out so nicely. Try it, and you'll see. To join, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. The link is also in the show notes.
今天感谢《美国生活》的合伙人苏珊·赫尔希、莱斯利·费林、加布里埃尔·罗德和彼得·詹姆斯。我希望你考虑加入他们成为终身合伙人。为什么？它让我们能够继续制作节目。我们预算的很大一部分现在来自我们的终身合伙人。我们希望这个数字能够增长。为了感谢你，我们将赠送你几十个我们制作出来的非常精彩的额外剧集。尝试一下，你就会明白了。要加入，请前往thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。链接也在节目笔记中。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. People are always walking up to him and asking him, how do I get into radio? And he always tells them--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。人们总是走近他，问他，我怎么进入广播业？他总是告诉他们——
So I mean, right away, the antennas go up.
所以我说，立刻，天线就竖起来了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
["COMING IN ON A WING AND A PRAYER" BY RY COODER]